Freak Show 2015.
Dein Einwand ist natürlich auch berechtigt und wir werden da später in der Sendung auch nochmal drauf eingehen, nicht wahr?
Und alles ganz strukturiert. Bei dieser Freak Show geht alles ganz geordnet zu.
Genau.
Im ersten Teil sprechen wir noch einmal über die WWDC und was nicht alles noch passiert ist in der Zwischenzeit. Wir sprechen ja heute mit Wortmeldungen, also Handzeichen geben und dann aufgerufen werden und erst dann wird gesprochen. Ich erteile dir das Wort.
Ja, vielen Dank Hucke für die Einführung. Das greife ich dann doch gleich mal auf.
Brauche aber WLAN. Aber wenn man sozusagen immer ums Haus rumläuft, wo WLAN ist...
Na ja gut, ich habe das jetzt nicht im Blick, wie viel Speicher so eine Watch-App denn jetzt unter Watcher S2 verbrauchen darf. Ja, kann sein. Aber es sind so um die 6, 5 bis 6 sind frei.
Ich glaube, 2 GB ist für Musik, aber das kann jetzt auch eine falsche Erinnerung sein.
Ja, die 2 GB, maximal 2 GB, sind für die Musik, die ich synchronisiere, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich mit der Musik-App von der Watch... Aber die Frage ist, wie viel eine Watch-App selber jetzt an Speicher sich genehmigen darf. Also, keine Ahnung. Das muss man abwarten. Die Hoffnung, dass die Watch-Apps dann deutlich schneller starten, das ist halt so die Erwartung, die ich dann habe. Das kann schon mal ein bisschen dauern. Es ist ja so, man hebt den Arm, dann klickt man da rum, startet eine App und dann kann es einem durchaus passieren, dass die Watch dunkel wird, bevor die App gestartet ist. Und das dann ein bisschen kloppt.
Oder sehr armschwer wird.
Ja, der wird sowieso in der Zeit... Also, diese Watch-Muskel, den hat man irgendwann drin.
Ja, das stimmt, weil jetzt kommt ja sozusagen, jetzt muss ja quasi die komplette iOS-App auf dem iPhone erst mal starten.
Naja, nicht die komplette App, nur die Extension, aber immerhin.
Ja, also da muss was starten.
Da muss was starten. Dann müssen die sich ein bisschen unterhalten.
Ja, und auch die Extension muss ja dann letzten Endes dasselbe tun, wie auch die richtige App. Also sie muss vielleicht nicht einen vollen Screen bedienen, aber sie muss irgendwie die Daten rausholen und was auch immer da sozusagen gerade das Thema ist bei dem Teil. Naja, also um es rund zu machen, Show's Promise. Ich habe es noch nicht bereut, hier eingestiegen zu sein. Und ich denke, wenn die Möglichkeit besteht, Podcasts zu hören und auf der Uhr Run-Tracking zu machen, dass ich nur mit Uhr- und Bluetooth-Kopfhörer unterwegs bin, das ist auf jeden Fall dann schon mal wieder so ein Schritt.
Also ich finde, die Notifications sind ein Killer. Die Watch-Apps selber momentan ja noch nicht so. Also da startet man selten mal irgendwie eine App, um irgendwas zu gucken. Das ist dann doch ein bisschen aufwendig. Aber wenn man eine Notification kriegt und man kann von der dann in die App, das ist dann schon ganz okay. Mitunter hängt ein bisschen von der App ab.
Es gibt so zwei, drei Apps, die sind schon sinnvoll, aber das ist definitiv noch nicht genug. Das stimmt.
Genau, heult doch, schreibt da einer. Aber es ist vielleicht nicht an uns gerichtet.
Vielleicht doch. Die Leute haben jetzt langsam genug vor dem Apple-Watch-Thema.
Ja, reicht auch.
Ja, reicht, genau.
Ja, reicht.
So.
Das muss ja auch mal gesagt werden. Aber ich weiß jetzt zumindest immer, was das Pfundwert ist. Auch wenn das ein bisschen deprimierend ist.
Ich wollte gleich so eine Bitcoin, das brauch ich ja gerade jetzt.
Ja, gibst du das noch nicht?
Ich hab keine Watch.
Das ist schade. Ja, jetzt sind wir willkommen zum nächsten Gesprächsthemenpunkt. Aber wir sind eigentlich immer noch bei Roddy. Oder wollen wir Roddy jetzt erstmal eine Pause geben?
Nee, das kann er ja noch kurz erzählen, dann ist das ja auch durch da.
Ach so, ja.
Das ist ja hoffentlich jetzt keine 2-Stunden-Geschichte.
Nein, nein, ist es nicht. In den zwei Wochen, die ich da war, waren natürlich auch ein Wochenende dazwischen. Und da habe ich dann endlich mal es geschafft, irgendwie mit anderen Kollegen einen längeren Ausflug zu machen. Und zwar ist es so, dass von Portland nicht weit entfernt, also was in Amerika nicht weit ist, zwei Autostunden ist nicht weit in Amerika. Ja, für manche Amerikaner ist auch das nicht weit. Ist ja dieser Mount St. Helens-Vulkan, der 1980 relativ spektakulär explodiert ist.
Zudem gibt es auch einen Film mit Piers Brosnan, der nicht besonders gut ist.
Und zwar deutlich spektakulärer als die Vereinigte Wissenschaftsgemeinde damals erwartet hatte, dass es passieren würde. Aber das nur am Rande. Wir sind da jetzt hingefahren und sind da ein bisschen rumgelaufen. Leider kann man da nicht mal so eben in den Vulkan rein. Naja, es ist so dieser Nationalpark, das sind irgendwie drei Zonen. Die Zone 1 ist gesperrt für Public. Die Zone 2, das ist im Prinzip die steile Flanke vom Vulkan, die ist, da kann man hin, aber man braucht einen Permit. Und die Permits für dieses Jahr sind bis Ende Oktober ausverkauft. Und die Zone 3, da kann man ohne Permit und Anmeldung hin, man darf nur nicht übernachten und man darf nicht von den ausgeschilderten Wegen abweichen, sonst kriegt man da irgendwie Ärger mit dem Ranger. Und ja, wir sind da so ein bisschen wandern gegangen. Und zwar ist, du bist jetzt auf der falschen Seite vom Vulkan.
Also ich hab jetzt hier gleich mal Kugelerde angestoßen.
Genau, du hast Kugelerde angestoßen. Da gibt es so eine Straße, die führt da in die Nähe. Und am Ende dieser Straße ist etwas, das nennt sich Johnston Observatory, heißt das Ding. Äh, zeigt er das an? Naja, das ist zumindest da. Da ist der große Parkplatz, und da ist dieses Johnston Observatory. Nein, nicht da. Jetzt weiter rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts. Genau, das Teil sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Bunker von Halo. Und von dort aus gibt es einen Wanderweg, irgendwie da so auf dem Ridge lang. Und am Ende von diesem Wanderweg kommt man dann nach unten und kommt dann so in dieses Tal von dem Trümmerfeld. Und ich war da so mit ein paar Kollegen unterwegs.
Was für ein Trümmerfeld?
Na, das ist...
Von dem Ausbruch.
Von dem damaligen Ausbruch, genau. Ja, da ist die steile Flanke.
Boah, da geht man so richtig an der Kante.
Jaja, das sieht aber gefährlicher aus als... Naja, vielleicht ist es auch gefährlicher als es aussieht, aber... Aber zumindest dahinter noch ein Stück den Weg weiter. Und dann gibt es diese Wegkreuzung da, die, die du da jetzt hast. An dieser Wegkreuzung wussten wir jetzt nicht genau, müssen wir da jetzt rechts ab oder geradeaus, wenn wir jetzt zu dem Trümmerfeld von dem Vulkan wollen. Und dann kamen aber von der einen Seite so zwei an, so ein Pärchen. Und ich hör schon so, oh, das sind Deutsche. Ja, weil, naja, wir haben sich halt so ein bisschen unterhalten. Und dann haben wir es mal so nach dem Weg gefragt. Und er hatte irgendwie so ein altes, so ein Garmin Standalone GPS-Gerät, weißt du, so mit...
Mit so einer dicken Starbantenne, ja, die so hochklappbar ist.
Nee, ohne Antenne, so ein Teil, was so im Wasser schwimmt und wo so eine eingebaute Karte hat und so weiter. Und da habe ich halt mal so gefragt, auf Deutsch, und er so, ja, dann müsst ihr da lang und so weiter. Und dann meinte er plötzlich so, sag mal, bist du der Roddy? Die Stimme kenne ich doch nicht so, ja. Und dann haben wir erstmal gelacht.
Freak Show-Hörer.
Und Martin, mein Kollege aus London, der da dabei war, der hat sehr ungläubig geguckt.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das ist auch wirklich eklig.
Also hier an dieser Stelle nochmal schöne Grüße an Christoph. Hat mich sehr gefreut. Wer mich sonst so bei einem Vulkan trifft, darf mich auch gerne grüßen, wenn er mich an der Stimme wieder erkennt. Ja und ansonsten, also es ist unheimlich schön, also gerade die Stelle hinter dem gefährlichen steilen Stück, wenn man da so in dieses Trümmer fällt, wo es diese kleinen Seen hat und so weiter reingeht, das ist wunderschön. Also es ist echt, es ist eine unglaubliche Landschaft. Wer die Gelegenheit hat, schaut euch das an. Das ist sehr trocken da, deswegen sieht man da halt auch immer noch die Bäume, die es zum Ausbruch umgenietet hat. Das müsstest du irgendwie auch in dem Satellitenbild erkennen können. Zumindest bei Apple Maps kann man das sehen.
Apple Maps war aber gerade nicht in der Lage, die Suche Mounts and Talents ausreichend zu bedienen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Rute mich.
Wenn ich in Liverpool gelande.
Auf jeden Fall, da ist es halt sehr trocken, deswegen sieht man die Bäume noch und deswegen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man sehr schönes Wetter hat, relativ hoch. Lustigerweise, wer hatte natürlich das Sonnenöl dabei? Der Australia. Naja, Sonnencreme, Sonnenmilch. Wer hatte da dran gedacht und immer dabei? Natürlich der Australia. Das war unser Glück.
Ozone Loch als erstes über dem Kopf, ne?
Naja, mehr oder weniger. Das ist die Kante. Der Krater, wie gesagt, Zone 1 darf man nicht rein. Der Rest, Zone 2. Mir hat ein anderer Kollege erzählt, einer von den Portland-Leuten, dass er das mal gemacht hat. Er ist da hoch und es ist unglaublich anstrengend, weil die gesamte Flanke vom Vulkan runter ist Asche. Und das ist so, als würde man den Strand im 45-Grad-Winkel rauflaufen. Man sinkt halt irgendwie mit dem Fuß immer so gute zehn Zentimeter ein und es ist unglaublich anstrengend.
Aber nicht giftig.
Heilend.
Irgendwo zwischen giftig und heilend.
Ja, das ist ja so mit der Medizin.
Genau.
Bei diesem einen Vulkan in Italien, der so Schwefel die ganze Zeit rausblubbert, da baden sich dann die Leute auch in irgendeinem Heilschlamm-Bedern gleich nebendran.
Ja, und so richtig still ist der Vulkan immer noch nicht. Also der Typ, der den Vortrag gehalten hat bei dem Observatory, der meinte, ja, da kommt ab und zu immer mal was raus. Aber die Lava hätte so die Konsistenz von Zahncreme. Deswegen hat sich in dem Krater halt noch mal so ein kleiner... Mini-Krater gebildet. So ein Kegel mehr, so ein Blob, so ein Dome. Also ja, doch. Wer die Chance hat, hinfahren, angucken.
Wen haben wir jetzt noch mal gegrüßt?
Christoph hieß er, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Aber Nummer 2 hörte nicht... Sagst du nicht, das wären zwei hingewiesen?
Ja, ich nehme an, seine Freundin war das. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Eine weibliche Person, die mit ihm war und die etwas unglaublich guckte. Also auch sehr unglaublich guckte, als er mich mit Namen ansprach. Bist du nicht. Und ich so, ja.
Lustig. Wer weiß, ob er jetzt Ärger kriegt, wenn seine Frau jetzt erfährt, dass er damit eine anderen war.
Du, man hat deine Hintergedanken drin.
Ja, aber nur, wenn die auch Freak Show hören. Lohnt sich halt immer Freak Show zu hören.
Keine weiteren Mutmaßungen. So, ja. Apropos Urlaub. Es ist Camp.
Aber erst nach dem Urlaub.
Aber davor haben wir noch eine Sendung.
Ja, ist ja egal. Aber jetzt kann man Tickets kaufen fürs Camp.
Nee, kann man nicht mehr.
Wie?
War nur Spaß. Ist noch nicht ausverkauft.
Wie ist denn der Stand, nachdem man da geklickt hat, sieht man ja die Grafen noch nicht mehr.
Also, tickets.events.ccc.de ist eure Adresse für alles, was man braucht, um aufs Camp zu kommen, nämlich ein Ticket. Und ja, diesmal kann man nicht nur was kaufen, sondern man kann auch den Preis dafür entsprechend einstellen. Also es gibt da sozusagen alle möglichen Güteklassen, Standard-Supporter 240, 260, 280, 300 mit den entsprechenden Preisen. Business Silver, Business Gold, Business Platinum und auch noch Lower Budget und Low Budget. Mit anderen Worten, wir würden gerne einen bestimmten Durchschnittspreis erzielen, um die Kosten zu decken. Der liegt so bei 210 Euro pro Ticket. Und das Schöne ist, dass wenn man auf diese Webseite schaut, dass es hier so eine Grafik gibt, die anzeigt, wie gerade so der durchschnittliche Ticketpreis ist. Also was sozusagen die bisher verkauften Tickets im Schnitt gebracht haben.
Die Merchandise rechnet sich jetzt da nicht mit rein, oder?
Die Merchandise rechnet sich da nicht rein. Aber frage mich bitte nicht zu viel Details, weil ich jetzt eigentlich auch nicht mehr weiß, als wir hier alle sehen.
Dass es diese Seite gibt?
Genau.
Also Merchandise heißt, man kann auch gleich T-Shirts mitbestellen, lalala. Und man sieht quasi an dieser anderen Grafik, was quasi derzeit so viele Umsätze gefahren werden. Das heißt, man sieht hier, dass Standard-Tickets den Löwen-Anteil ausmachen, Supporter-Tickets aber auch signifikant dazu beitragen.
Und immer mehr Leute Low-Budget kaufen, weil wir über dem Durchschnitt liegen, ja? Oder wie verstehe ich das?
Na, Leute halt auch zu Low-Budget greifen, und das ist ja auch in Ordnung so, weil wir wissen alle, dass auch 180 Euro für viele Leute einfach nicht wenig Geld sind. Das muss man auch erstmal abknapsen können. Und während man sich anreisen und so ähnliche Sachen und Ausrüstung irgendwie alles noch zusammenleihen und schnorren kann, ist das halt bei so einem Ticket nicht so ohne Weiteres machbar.
Wer hat denn bitteschön die Farbe Aubergine mit Eggplant übersetzt? Also ist die richtig übersetzt, aber ich meine, nennt man die Farbe im Englischen Eggplant?
Also zumindest im T-Shirt-Business, glaube ich. Na gut, na so heißt es. Da machen die sich gar keine weiteren Gedanken drüber.
Ja, ich mag das Wort auch überhaupt gar nicht, aber...
Weil die Eierpflanze... Nur wir haben uns halt so ein schönes französisches Wort dafür entgegen.
Ich sag ja mal Herbergsfrucht. Weil es ja die Aubergine.
Ist das ein real thing? Also ich meine, ist das tatsächlich... Gibt's das? Nein.
Nee, was heißt denn Aubergine?
Herbergs Pflanze. Oder was?
Nein, was heißt Aubergine? Französisches Wort.
Jaja, du hast ja...
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich nenne es halt so.
Ja, ist sehr egal. Frucht, Herbergs Pflanze, Herbergs. Herbergine. Also hier gibt es eine Webseite, die tatsächlich behauptet, dass französische Aubergine bedeutet Herbergsfrucht. Naja, also jetzt hast du mich ganz auf ein Konzept gebracht. Auf jeden Fall kommt mal zum Camp. Da gibt es auch viele Gründe dazu, da hinzukommen. Ein paar haben wir hier, glaube ich, auch schon mal erwähnt. Ist lustig. Viele interessante Leute da, viel zu sehen.
Viel Party.
Mehr Party als im Kongress.
Noch mehr? Ja, wie man es... Naja, auf jeden Fall...
Geht gar nicht anders, man bleibt ja vor Ort.
Kein Mangel an Unterhaltung. Und es wird auch Podcasts geben, die dort live zum Gemüte geführt werden können. Sagt man das so? Nee, zum konsumiert angeschaut... Besucht werden können. Genau.
Aufs Ohr.
Genau. Dazu wird auch die Freak Show gehören. Das heißt, wenn ihr schon immer mal Freak Show live erleben wolltet und es bisher noch nicht getan habt, oder es schon mal getan habt und nicht genug davon bekommen könnt, dann macht sich quasi allein das Camp-Ticket schon dadurch bezahlt. Also ich meine, was kostet denn heute ein Konzert-Ticket? Da ist mal auch mal ein 100 Euro dabei, oder?
Also Festival kostet... Richtig.
Auch alle möglichen andere Konferenzen kosten.
Also 200 mindestens. 200 mindestens. Ich glaube, dieses Dänische, wie heißt es doch gleich?
Roskilde.
Roskilde kostet 200.
Seid ihr denn dann auch mit Instrument an Bord, Hucke?
Was ist hier mit, wie heißt nochmal euer Auto? Kommt auch Auto. Gibt es auch ein Autokonzert?
Das ist jetzt noch nicht angedacht, ne?
Ich muss jetzt reingeredchen. Sag mal Hucke, euer Album-Name, ja? Wie war das? PS Ich Liebe Dich.
Das war jetzt so eine Idee, ja.
Und die Idee war die PS Doppelpunkt oder PS Komma?
Doppelpunkt. Doppelpunkt.
Weil da war letztendlich so ein, so ein, der, der Spiegel, die da immer überschritten.
Ja, ich hab's auch gesehen.
Das war nämlich mit Komma, ne, weil PS halt. Also du hast da keine Wortspielchen im Sinn gehabt.
Wenn da jemand einen Komma setzt, dann sollte man ihn gleich feuern. Wie auch immer, die, also ein Autokonzert.
Ding halt um Fahren und um PS.
Autokonzert. Na ja, ich bin ja da auf dem Kongress. Also wenn sich die Veranstaltung, also die Planung so vollzieht, wie mir das jetzt zugetragen wurde, dann bin ich ja so anderweitig angebunden schon. Angebunden. Eingebunden, ja.
Eingebunden.
Ich wurde eingebunden.
Dauerhaft.
Na ja, am Anfang und am Ende.
Wir verraten jetzt mal noch nicht so viel. Aber wir schauen mal, was sich so machen lässt.
Ja, also...
Und wollen die musikalische Einlage?
Also wir können ja irgendwie das Rocker-Village irgendwie noch aufmachen. Stellen wir ein Drum-Kit rein, ein Bass.
Ich denke natürlich jetzt ausschließlich an unsere Live-Freak-Show. Und überhaupt, wir haben eigentlich noch nicht sehr viele Ideen wirklich zu Ende entwickelt, wie wir das da so machen wollen. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht machen wir was Lustiges. Vielleicht habt ihr ja Ideen.
Vielleicht machen wir was Lustiges. Aber wahrscheinlich wird es total dröge.
Oder wir machen einen schönen Test. Wir bauen so Bierkästenstapeln auf. Und dann ist die Challenge irgendwie so, den Bierkasten gerade so hoch zu stapeln, dass wenn man eine Apple Watch von oben runterschmeißt, sie nicht in zwei Teile zerbricht.
Auf der Wiese.
Na, da legt man dann vielleicht noch eine Marmorplatte unter.
Irgendwas mit höherer Bewegung, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist doch wohl höherer Bewegung.
Ja, was sich Türme von Hanoi nachspielen mit Markekästen oder irgendwas. Also wir sind da auch für Ideen aufgeschlossen. Ihr dürft die gerne in unsere Richtung schmeißen, ob wir die dann aufgreifen. Steht auf dem anderen Blatt. Aber es soll auf jeden Fall alles sehr unterhaltsam werden auf diesem ganzen Camp und wir sind bereit, einen Beitrag dazu zu leisten. Und deswegen müsst ihr alle dahin kommen, weil das Camp ist geil und macht Spaß. Und kauft irgendwie ein richtig schön teures Ticket, wenn ihr so klug seid und euch die Konferenz als Arbeitsausflug anzusetzen. Ja, habe ich zum Beispiel gemacht. Genau, da erzählt man, wie man das macht. Also man geht dann zusammen.
Ja, bei uns ist das eigentlich so, wir haben halt so, man kann so 1500 Euro quasi frei ausgeben für Education, also Bücher, Konferenzen, was auch immer. Ja, und ich habe jetzt mal gefragt, weil es jetzt bei uns, also bei dem Camp, so viele Staffelungen gibt und die ja auch nicht ganz doof sind, die gucken halt auch mal so die Konferenz dann nach, wo man halt hingeht und wenn er dann so steht, ja, hätte er jetzt auch ein Ticket für 180 haben können, sage ich mal, warum hat er jetzt das mittelteuer genommen? Also ich habe das für 450 jetzt besorgt, aber ich bin halt vorher noch mal bei den Finance-Damen vorbeigegangen, meinte so, wie sieht es aus? Habt ihr da ein Problem mit? Weil letztendlich darf ich entscheiden. Imagineur, solange dein Teammeister irgendwie da seine Unterschrift runtersetzt, ist uns das wurscht und dann, ja, habe ich das mal in die Wege geleitet.
Sehr schön.
Also ich hätte wahrscheinlich auch noch mehr, aber ich will noch eine andere Konferenz, nämlich den Kongress am Ende.
Wobei, es wäre dann in den selben Topf gegangen. Genau, also seid kreativ und je nachdem, was ihr für Möglichkeiten habt. Die Veranstaltung braucht das Geld wirklich, weil das ist eine enorme Anstrengung und auch eine enorme finanzielle Anstrengung in diesem Jahr. Definitiv.
Ich weiß nicht. Da schlug noch jemand vor, wer kann bei zehn Armbewegungen die Apple Watch zehnmal einschalten?
Ja, das macht ihr dann alles in den Kommentaren. So, überhaupt dieses Draußenleben ist ja...
Draußen mit Netz.
Draußen mit Netz ist ja gerade wieder ange... Ich hatte jetzt auch draußen, aber nicht so viel Netz. Ja, ich war irgendwie nach zehn Jahren das erste Mal wieder auf der Fusion. Weiß jeder, was die Fusion ist?
Ja, schon mal gehört.
Genau. Also Fusion Festival ist eine ziemlich enorme Veranstaltung. Kann man nicht anders sagen. Enorm schon allein von den Teilnehmerzahlen her.
Das schreckt mich auch ab, ich bin eher so der kleine Festival.
Ja, hat mich auch abgeschreckt. Das kann einen dann auch vor Ort partiell abschrecken, aber das ändert auch nichts daran, dass diese Veranstaltung an sich einfach irre geil ist.
Hast du denn mit dem einfachen Pöbel gezeltet? Oder hast du dir da so eine Deluxe de la Cac-Ecke irgendwo organisiert, die dir das ganze Festival vielleicht etwas angenehmer erscheinen hat lassen?
Es gab eine recht zentrale Positionierung, da, wie du ja weißt, in unserem Umfeld auch einige Anstrengungen vorgenommen werden, diese Veranstaltung auch digital zu unterfüttern. Von daher bewegt man sich da vielleicht in anderen Camping-Zonen. Aber das erinnert nichts an der Tatsache, dass es da sehr nett war. Ich war vor allem sehr viel an einem ganz neuen Zelt, was es nämlich bisher noch so nicht gab. Und was eine ganz interessante Idee ist, weswegen ich das jetzt überhaupt erst erwähne. Es gab nämlich dann auf dieser Fusion, also muss ich noch mal kurz sagen, Fusion ist sozusagen aus dieser elektronischen Tanzmusik-Szene Mitte der 90er Jahre hervorgegangen, hat jetzt glaube ich so zum 18. Mal stattgefunden. Und ist vor allem, wie der Name auch schon sagt, sehr breit aufgestellt. Das heißt, es gibt da sehr viel unterschiedliche Musik, alles Mögliche, aber auch nicht nur Musik, sondern auch Theater, Cabaret, allen möglichen Wahnsinn, der da abläuft. Alles sehr bunt, ist halt so ein ehemaliges Militärgelände, so ein Flughafen mit unzähligen Bunkern, die aber alle überhaupt nicht mehr, also so Flugzeughanggas, die alle überhaupt nicht mehr danach aussehen, weil die mittlerweile schon so dicht dekoriert sind, dass das alles so ein bisschen wie so eine Zauberwelt rüberkommt. Aber es geht halt da vor allem natürlich ums draußen sein, feiern Leute treffen.
Ohne Flugzeughanggas geht gar nichts mehr heutzutage, oder?
Naja, und es gibt eine ähnliche Veranstaltung in Portugal, die heißt Boom Festival. Und da gab es wohl schon seit ein paar Jahren auch noch so ein Zelt, wo, naja, Content war. Also wo Content, ja, wo Inhalte geboten wurden, sprich kleine Vorträge zu bestimmten Themen. Sagen wir mal so, wie wir das vom Camp her halt kennen. Und das wurde jetzt auch auf der Fusion das erste Mal gemacht und das fand ich auch sehr gelungen. Das heißt, da gab es dann einige sehr nette Vorträge. Unter anderem war hier das Zentrum für politische Schönheit vor Ort. Vom Club waren diverse Leute aus der netzpolitischen Szene vor Ort und haben halt über alles Mögliche erzählt. Und wie mache ich Krypto und wie verteidigen wir die Freiheit? Pipapo, aber eben auch viel Meta-Content zum Kulturmanagement von solchen alternativen Szenekonzepten. Das fand ich auch sehr interessant. Also da ist einiges zu hören. Und da werden vor allem auch die Vorträge demnächst im Netz landen. Das heißt, dann kann man sich das irgendwie alles mal anschauen, was da gelaufen ist und das ist auf jeden Fall einen Blick wert, wenn es das dann gibt, werde ich das dann hier auch irgendwann noch mal in die Show notes nachtragen und irgendwie die Öffentlichkeit tragen. Jetzt gerade gibt es das, soweit ich weiß, noch nicht. Aber schön. Content zählt.
Sehr hübsch.
Das gibt es dann auf dem Camp auch, aber da liegt halt dann auch der Fokus drauf. Auf Content.
Das ist jedes Zelt Content.
Ich habe ja noch nie auf dem Camp einen Vortrag gesehen. Echt nicht? Also ich habe letztes Jahr gezählt. Das ist jetzt das fünfte Camp, ne? Ich habe ja das erste knapp verpasst. Da bin ich ja gerade erst im Club so angelandet. Da war das gerade vorbei. Und dann auf den anderen war irgendwie so viel anderes dann immer interessant, dass die Vorträge selber bei irgendwie auch meistens gutem Wetter in diesen Vortragssälen mich oder Hangars nicht so mega gereizt haben. Ja, weil auf dem Camp will man eigentlich auch mehr gucken und kennenlernen und unterhalten und entdecken.
Das finde ich auch ganz gut, dass der Sog da nicht so groß ist, weil wir diese Kapazitäten überhaupt gar nicht bieten könnten. Aber ganz ohne ist ja auch nichts.
Ne, ne, also sollte schon natürlich, klar. Das wäre ja dann quasi hier, wenn man die 5 mit der Hand quasi in binär zählt, dann ist das ja voll der, äh, krasser Stinkerfinger.
So, kommen wir zu OSX. Darüber muss auch mal gesprochen werden.
Wir würden ja mehr über Max reden, ne?
Ja.
Du hast jetzt das Apple Music hingeschoben hier.
Ich glaub, du musst doch mit dem Trim, mit deinem anfangen.
Ja, aber wo hat er, ach, das hat er schon noch weiter runtergeschoben.
Ich muss damit anfangen, da gibt's ja nicht sehr viel zu erzählen eigentlich.
Ich hab ja erst Tim Force gelesen und dachte mir, krass.
Okay, ich fang mal an. Also ich hab ja in der letzten Sendung schon erzählt, dass man bei dem El Capitan 10.11, Wie?
Eleven?
Ja, dass man da mit einem Trim Force Kommando den Trim Support für SSDs einschalten kann, die nicht von Apple sind, weil Apple macht Trim Support nur für eigene SSDs. Aber da bei El Capitan ging das nicht so einfach, weil man musste erst den sogenannten Rootless-Mode einschalten. Dann musste man booten, ich glaube in den Emergency-Modus oder Recovery-Modus, da dann den Trim Force starten und wenn man das dann hatte, konnte man den Rootless-Modus wieder ausschalten und konnte wieder in sein normales OS zurückbooten, irgendwie so. Und das hat den Grund, es gibt bei dem El Capitan ein neues Security-Feature. Das nennt sich SIP oder auch System Integrity Protection. Und zwar ist das eigentlich auch wieder eine uralte Sache, die es bei Linux, FreeBSD, NetPSD und so weiter schon seit länger gibt, als ich mich damit beschäftige. Und zwar gibt es... FreeBSD, NetPSD, alle Unix, Linux hat das auch vielleicht ein bisschen anders, aber ich hab mal gefragt, die haben das auch. Das sind... Wie heißen die? File System Flex? File Flex? Wie nennt man die? Welche? Na hier, RWD. Wie heißen die genau? Flex. Permission Flex? File Permissions. Irgendwie so. Ihr wisst schon, was ich meine.
Die Flex halt.
Die Flex.
Na die heißen Flex, das kann man nur als CH-Flex.
Und da gibt es halt Flex. Das wissen auch gar nicht so viele. Da könnte man Leute schön mit ärgern, wenn man mal ganz große Route hat. Und zwar kann man, wirklich, kann man einen File unchangeable machen. Und das kriegst du dann auch mit Route nicht mehr weg. Das heißt, das ist dann unchangeable. Was du machen musst, um das wieder wegzukriegen ist, du musst in den Single-User-Mode gehen. Wenn dein Rechner aber schon gebootet ist, um in den Single-User-Mode zu kommen, müsstest du eigentlich alle Prozesse wieder stoppen. Mehr oder weniger läuft da nichts mehr, wenn du im Single-User-Mode bist. Und das geht nicht. Das heißt, eigentlich musst du dann booten, um das wieder wegzukriegen. Das andere Flag, was man noch setzen kann... Ihr könnt einfach bei CH-Flex in die Main-Page gucken und dann steht, dass dann nochmal genauer erklärt ist. Bei MacOS, bei OSX auch dabei, könnt ihr nachgucken. Das ist die zweite Seite oder so. Also, müsst ihr ein bisschen runterscrollen, da steht das alles. Und das andere Flag, was man setzen kann, das ist dann auch ein Security-Feature. Man kann ein Flag setzen, das heißt SAPEND oder S-A-P-P-N-D. Das sorgt dafür, dass wenn ihr einen Lockfail habt, das ist nicht immutable, sondern man kann nur noch Sachen anhängen, wie bei einem Lockfail. Aber der Hacker, der sozusagen irgendwas macht und dann das aus dem Lockfail entfernen will, weil das machen die sehr gerne, damit man sie nicht entdecken kann, der kann das dann nicht wieder entfernen. Also, er kann es nur input, aber man kann nichts mehr entfernen von diesem Lockfail. Das ist eigentlich auch ein cooles Security-Feature. Und diese Flag, die nutzt Apple jetzt seit El Capitan um den System-Folder, oder was heißt Folder? Die System Directory, die man halt slash System, wo der Colonel drin... Nee, der Colonel liegt da auch drin. Nee, da liegt er direkt in slash. Aber der ist wahrscheinlich auch protected. Jedenfalls ganz System, System Library Extensions, die ganzen Colonel Extensions und so weiter, die unter System liegen. Die sind alle jetzt immutable. Und man kann den nicht mehr ändern. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch ein Virus einfangt, oder was auch immer, der kann zwar eine Menge Shit machen, aber er kann euer System nicht komplett ändern. Oder zum Beispiel auch eure... Ich weiß nicht, was in dem System alles drin liegt, aber er kann jedenfalls nicht komplett das System übernehmen.
Extensions.
Das muss er zumindest erstmal aushebeln.
Das geht ja nicht, weil du kannst diese Protection nicht wegnehmen.
Nur im Single-User-Mode?
Genau, dafür müsstest du booten.
Heißt das, dass ich auch mit Rm-Rf den Systemfolder nicht entfernen kann?
Ja, müsste nicht mehr gehen.
Also gilt das wirklich für alles, oder gilt das nur für manches?
Nein, man kann sich die Flex mit einem LS-Kommando angucken. Ich habe es nur leider vergessen. Ich glaube, es war Groß-O oder was? Klein-O? LS-Flex? Kann das einer mal schnell herausfinden. Ich bin ja schlecht vorbereitet, wie immer. Letztens wusste ich es noch. Na, man kann LS eine Option geben, dass einem diese Flex, die man normalerweise nicht sieht, die angezeigt werden.
Dieses SCSCHG.
Minus O einfach?
Groß-O.
Groß-O hatte ich doch, aber gerade hier ist alles... Ach so, ich muss natürlich mir von Slash anzeigen lassen. Genau, hier kannst du das sehen. Jetzt ist zum Beispiel hier...
Mama auf Groß hier.
Mach du das, du hast keinen El Capitan.
Wir sind doch hier ein modernes Podcaststudio. Du kannst jetzt mal hier einfach auf das Apple TV...
Das ist super, die Hörer können uns zwar immer noch nicht sehen, aber wir können.
Aber immerhin wissen wir, wovon wir reden.
Ja, okay, jetzt ist das aber hier ein extra Fenster. Und nicht meins, wo ist es hier? Genau. Ich mach das mal jetzt ein bisschen... So, und jetzt habe ich hier mal ein LS, Leerzeichen, minus LA und dann noch ein O hintendran gemacht. Großes O, genau. Und zwar auf Slash, also auf den Root Directory. Und da kommen jetzt zusätzlich zu den normalen Flakes, die man sieht, steht jetzt noch da, dass manche Directories hidden sind, was ja normal ist. Hier Punkte, Trashes zum Beispiel oder die Spotlight-Files, irgendwie Hotfile, Punkt, B-Tree, also Filesystem, was auch immer die da drin speichern, will man alles gar nicht wissen eigentlich.
Also sie tauchen im Finder dann nicht auf.
Genau, das kann man da sehen. Das gibt es wahrscheinlich unter dem normalen Yosemite auch schon. Kannst du hier mal probieren?
Ja, ich habe es hier gerade aufgerufen.
Hast du da diese hidden auch schon?
Ja, ja, alles, was da als hidden bezeichnet ist, unter Yosemite auch hidden.
Das wurde früher auch schon eingestellt, das ist, was man unter dem Finder nicht sehen soll. Jetzt gibt es da zusätzlich auch noch ein restricted. Zum Beispiel system-restricted. Bidden ist restricted, Chores und Dev und Home sogar. Wahrscheinlich muss man Home nicht löschen, der Inhalt ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Ah, nee, das ist hidden. Wo sind wir noch restricted?
User ist restricted.
Ja, S-Bin und User ist auch restricted. War und Temp auch sogar.
Das wird ja interessant für die Brew-Leute, oder?
Na, die sind doch eh ein Opt, oder nicht?
Aber was genau heißt das?
Nee, die sind ein User.
Na, du kannst das nicht laschen.
Ich denke, das heißt immutable.
Ja, warum da jetzt restricted steht, ist mir auch nicht so ganz klar. Wo ist meine Maus? Ich finde meine Maus nicht klar.
Also, restricted bedeutet bestimmt nochmal ein bisschen was anderes.
Ich gehe mal in Slash System rein und mache mal hier ein Sodo, nein, ein Touch, man, ich kann nicht tippen, ein Touch X. Sagt mir, geht nicht. So, jetzt mache ich ein Sodo vorne dran, ja, Password, ich bin an einer anderen Stelle als ihr da so, damit ihr nicht zugucken könnt. Und dann sagt er, ist immer noch nicht bemühtet. Also ich kann jetzt selbst mit Sodo in System nicht mehr eine Datei anlegen. Na, Slash User ist ja...
Ist ja auch restricted hinten hier.
Ja, ich gucke da mal direkt rein. Nee, wenn ich drin bin, ist es nicht mehr restricted. Du kannst den User selbst nicht...
Users ist ja auch nicht restricted.
Ach du meinst das kleine User, das meinst du. Ja, es gibt noch ein großes User mit einem E drin. Da haben wir ja wieder was gelernt.
Ja, das sagst du auch immer die ganze Zeit, ne? Slash user system resources slash local slash...
Buckel, ich bin alt. Ich hab nur den alten Scheiß, um angeben zu können.
Und sagst du das, wenn du das so vor dich hin brabbelst? Oder was sagst du dann? Du sagst USR.
Wofür steht denn ETC?
Extraterrestrial Commands.
Das hatten wir aber auch schon. Kleinen Scheißerwerten hab ich ja auch schon erzählt, dass eigentlich SU nicht für Super-User steht, sondern für Substitut-User. Das machen ja auch viele falsch. Ist egal, die Grundstory hier ist, dass Apple jetzt mit diesem System Integrity Protection sein OS ein bisschen dichter macht.
Aber guck da nochmal ein bisschen in System-Library, ob du irgendwo... Mach doch mal so ein ls-lao-system und dann pipest du das mal nach grep.
ls-lao-system, ja und dann? Dann grep und dann nach Restricted oder was?
Restricted sehen wir ja schon. Eines von diesen anderen Flecks, das muss doch in der Manual-Patch auch noch drinstehen, was es sonst noch nicht gibt. Ich meine, wenn das jetzt nur eine einzige Fleck ist...
Aber die anderen sind nicht nur im Single-User-Mode endbar. Das steht auch in diesem Change-Flex drin.
Also eigentlich geht es nur um dieses eine einzige Fleck. Und das heißt Restricted. Und das heißt soviel wie darf nur vom Super-User im Single-User-Modus geändert werden. Und nicht im normalen Laufzeit-Modus.
Genau.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich total read-only und man kann diesen System-Fuller überhaupt nicht mehr beschreiben. Das heißt, diese bekloppten Installer von irgendwelchen Programmen, die jetzt eine Extension im System-Ordner installieren wollen, die werden auch komplett failen.
Na das war schon immer...
Da gehören sie ja sowieso nicht hin.
Telekom, Internetmanager.
Legen nicht auch die ganzen Audio-Plugins da irgendwie?
Die gehören auch alle in den anderen. Das werden die jetzt lernen, überhaupt die harte Methode. Dann gibt es da den Shitstorm und dann geht es los. Ich meine, ja, ist halt so.
Also ich gucke mal gerade, oder liegt die doch in der anderen Library?
Das war bei Apple eigentlich schon nur aufgetrennt zwischen System-Library-Extension und Normal-Library-Extension. Also es gibt alles zweimal und schon seit immer. Viele machen es inzwischen eigentlich auch ordentlich. Also manche werden es jetzt auf die harte Methode lernen.
Ich finde das auch gut.
Und man kann sehen, dass wir das jetzt auch schon lange vorbereitet haben, glaube ich jedenfalls, weil ja schon seit einer Weile, wenn man den Installer startet, der ist dann relativ schnell fertig und dann wird gebootet und dann installiert er eigentlich erst los. Und das kann er halt machen. Das brauchst du ja als Grundlage, damit du mit diesen...
Der legt sie halt erstmal irgendwo hin und sagt, hier ist das, was du installieren sollst. Dann bootet er in Single-User-Modus.
Und macht das von da, weil da darf er das ändern und kann das dann auch einschalten.
Und deswegen bootet er auch danach nochmal. Genau. Macht doch nochmal ganz kurz Mann CH Flex, damit wir mal kurz schauen können, was es außer Restricted noch gibt, weil in dem alten CH Flex ist nämlich so viel auch nicht drin.
Da steht hier in dem... steht auch gar nichts von Restricted. Da steht halt dieses Hidden Hamse da und...
CHG ist auch noch so ein klassisches...
Ah ja genau, ich wollte gucken, ob dieses Append irgendwo gesetzt ist. Also ob sie die Log-Files...
Ja, das müsste man ja eher in die Log-Files gucken.
Genau, guck doch mal in Warlog, was da so ist.
Übrigens dieses SCHG-Flake, das hat mir auch schon oft den letzten Nerv geraubt, wenn das auf irgendwelchen Files geht.
Da kann man Leute mit ändern, weil normalerweise mit LS du siehst das erstmal nicht und du bist dann am Arsch und kriegst das nicht weg und wunderst dich und so. Hat mir der Herr Hans Haarpunkt mal beigebracht, ganz früher. Was? Das mit diesen Flaks, die man nicht sieht und mit dem Immutable und so.
Metadaten.
Er ist ja auch fies, weil die werden normalerweise nicht angezeigt. So gesehen hat man erst mal lange nichts damit zu tun.
Ja, aber diese Lockfiles hier sind noch nicht so.
Ja, die laufen ja auch irgendwann voll und dann willst du die ja auch hier wegpacken und zur Seite. Das würde dann alles nicht mehr gehen. Also so gesehen, da will man schon sich überlegen, was man da macht.
Löschen kann man sie vielleicht trotzdem noch, weiß ich nicht.
Dann könnte der Hacker die auch löschen, dann wären sie auch weg. Das nützt ja dann nichts.
Geht es nur um Hacker? Das System könnte sie weg rotieren und sie dann löschbar machen.
Ja, aber wie denn, wenn es das nur im Single User Modus kann?
Dann musst du irgendwie beim Booten einmal durch den Single User Modus drücken.
Ja, aber wenn dein Rechner jetzt hier zwei Monate läuft, was jetzt nicht so unwahrscheinlich ist, also ich boote meinen Rechner nicht freiwillig, dass nur wenn ein Update kommt.
Also mit einigen Worten, Apple versaut uns die Uptime.
Das tut sie auch anders.
Apple sorgt dafür, dass die Extensions jetzt von Fremdherstellern da landen, wo sie landen sollen.
Ich mache ja immer noch diesen Unicus. Letztens habe ich mal wieder jemand in der freien Wildbahn gesehen, der nach Beendigung der Arbeit geflissentlich auf den Power-Button drückte und die Maschine herunterfuhr und auf die Frage, warum machst du denn den Computer aus, ganz verdutzt reagierte und gar nicht verstanden hat, was ich denn jetzt als Alternative wohl vorzuschlagen hätte. Ja wieso? Soll der etwa anbleiben? Ja, da muss ich auch einmal einen kleinen Extra-Lehrauftrag erfüllen.
Also, kommen wir zurück. Wo waren wir? Bei Trimforce, was man unterm El Capitan nur mit der Umgehung von diesem System Integrity Protection einschalten kann. Viele haben gedacht, dass es Trimforce wahrscheinlich nur mit El Capitan kommt, aber gestern kam ja 10.10.4, damit wir alle irgendwie die neuesten Security-Feeshirts kriegen. Mit der Musik hat es gar nicht so viel zu tun. Ich denke, 10.10.3 Leute können auch Apple Music hören jetzt, oder? Okay, dann hat das abgebildet.
Es gab ja für Mavericks auch ein Security-Update und ein EFI-Update, aber auch das wird hoffentlich nichts mit der Musik zu tun gehabt haben.
Jedenfalls kann man, große Freude auch, unter 10.10.4 mit diesem Trim Force-Kommando den Trim Support für nicht-Apple-SSDs einschalten. Und da es da diesen System Integrity Protection noch nicht gibt, braucht man noch keinen Routes-Mode und kein Nix, sondern schaltet es einfach ein und es geht. Habe ich jetzt selber noch nicht probiert, weil mein Rechner zu Hause hat eine Apple-SSD drin und deswegen ist es kein Problem.
Das ist eigentlich interessant für alle Leute, die mal in ihren HD, mit HD-bestückten Laptops eine SSD nachgerüstet haben, oder die in Mac Pro fahren, oder in iMac, wo noch eine Festplatte drin war. Überall, wo noch mal eine Festplatte drin war, die man ersetzt hat.
Eine SSD, Festplatte ist egal.
Nein, also ein Rechner, wo man selber eine einbauen konnte, weil wäre das nicht gewesen, könnte man auch keine SSD reintun, weil sonst ist ja alles eingebaut. Habe ich jetzt mal eingeschaltet, bei Mac Pro hat es noch funktioniert danach.
Ja, man kann noch ganz einfach checken in Trim Support. Man geht hier über diesen Mac, oder wie es auf Deutsch heißt, geht dann auf System Report, geht dann in der linken Leiste auf SATA, dann sieht man da seine Platten, und wenn man eine SSD hat, dann gibt es da einen Eintrag, da heißt es Trim Support, und dahinter steht ja oder nein, oder yes oder no, und daran kann man sehen, ob es geht oder nicht, und da sollte eigentlich auf yes stehen.
Da schaue ich doch mal rein.
Und bei Timmer steht da auch yes. Obwohl da oben als Model bei ihm Samsung steht.
Ja, man muss nur aufpassen. Es gibt ein paar wenige SSDs, die scheiße bauen, wenn man Trim an schaltet. Diese Samsung 7000er Serie oder so war das, glaube ich.
Ja, und die SSD 850 war auch dabei. Hatten wir auch schon in der letzten Sendung. Ja, aber das nutzt irgendein komisches Feature von irgendwie SATA 3.1 oder noch 3.2. Das nutzt Apple gar nicht, deswegen bist du raus. Auf Apple ist das gar kein Problem, weil die nutzen dieses Feature nicht. Die sind dann noch gar nicht so weit. Das ist wohl ein relativ modernes Feature, wo man da Probleme kriegt und das gibt es bei Apple noch gar nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, müsst ihr jetzt mal raussuchen, aber ich hatte da so einen Artikel irgendwie weitergetweetet, wo so eine Bude irgendwie bei ihren Servern merkwürdige Probleme hatten und es dann auf Trim zurückgeführt haben.
Naja, dann kann ja der Typ, der den Trim in der Lage geschrieben hat, sich jetzt ein neues Feld aussuchen.
Ja, ich glaube, er hat ja seinen Trimminator schon irgendwie erweitert. Da gab es irgendwas. Ich hatte mal so ein Tool, ich weiß nicht, war das Beta, ist das nie was geworden, wo halt das Tool sich gemerkt hat, wie lange denn eine SSD schon läuft und wie gut sie noch ist und all sowas. So ein bisschen so ein SSD-Checker oder so. Oder war das von jemandem anderem? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr. Ist aber auch schon ewig, ja.
Naja, auf jeden Fall sind sie eingeknickt und man kann jetzt anschalten.
Und hast du beim Kapitän, den du da begutachten hast, noch irgendwelche Besonderheiten gesehen? Also ich habe gesehen, dass die, dass sie das GUI wieder gerade gebürstet haben. Das geschieht ja zu meiner größten...
Naja, gerade gebürstet, finde ich jetzt.
Safari 9.0.
Sie haben das gefixt, was mich am meisten gestört hat.
Das Thema hat gestört, dass die Buttons in Safari in der obersten Leiste, dass die nicht so schattiert sind, wie er es gerne hätte.
Ja, es hat für mich wirklich ein Wahrnehmungsproblem erzeugt. Weil sich einfach dieses Grau in Grau, das milchige... Ich fand ja gerade an dem GUI von Mountain Line fand ich so gut, dass es war ja nicht so mehr so farblich überladen und auch nicht so Textur überladen, sondern es war halt im Wesentlichen dieses dominante, dunkle, grau, so was die ganzen Konturen gemacht hatten und sie hatten halt die Konturen für meinen Geschmack auf den Punkt gebracht. Also es war einfach dieser, das Kontrast, der Kontrastlevel, dieses OS, der GUI, der war einfach, da hat man jetzt gesehen, das hat jetzt irgendwie zehn Jahre Reife und sitzt. Und dann kam hier Jose Mite, die alte Termite. Und hat irgendwie alles so wieder so weggeblört und auf einmal war alles nur so halb seiten, milchig, grau und gerade auch in diesem Safari, diesem Standard, Fensteroptik, das weiß ich nicht, mich hat das irgendwie total wuschig gemacht und ich bin sehr froh, dass sich das jetzt ändert.
Ich habe es ja bisher ausgesessen. Ich habe mir jetzt so einen Fashion-Sata-Adapter geschnappt und eine alte 2,5 Zoll Festparte genommen und habe mal seit langem wieder eine Time Machine Backup gemacht, als Vorbereitung jetzt doch endlich mal Jujosemite zu installieren. Dann haben ja alle gesagt, warte noch bis 10.10.04. Das ist jetzt draußen. Ich habe gestern erst wieder frisch nach Timemachiniert. Das heißt, theoretisch wäre ich jetzt ready, aber jetzt denke ich mir auch, vielleicht warte ich es einfach jetzt noch bis der Kapitän noch bis 10.11.04.
Aber dann ist da wieder so ein großer Schwung und dann hast du eventuell ganz viele Probleme auf einmal. Ich würde für dich die meisten jetzt schon mal abarbeiten. Wenn es dann rauskommt, dann hast du das schon mal hinter dir.
Das ist so eine verrückte Entwicklung. Das ist aber auch dem Audio geschuldet. Und ein bisschen, dass ich halt so mein ganzes Arbeitssetup ja, also ich habe ja nur einen Rechner, den ich für Haken, für Geld und Haken zu Hause benutze. Und deswegen will ich halt mein Arbeitssetup, für das ich bezahlt werde, auch nicht einfach mit so einem Update zerstören. Deswegen bin ich halt echt jetzt so konservativ geworden. Früher habe ich ja auch jede Alpha und Beta und was nicht noch alles draufgehauen. Und jetzt sitze ich hier und überlege, bei 10, 10, 4 vielleicht mal abzudaten.
Das nennt man Altersweisheit. Willkommen im Club.
Na oder bzw. Geld verdienen hängt vom funktionierenden Setup ab. Und früher war halt noch nicht so viel mit Geld verdienen. Da konnte man auch mal hinnehmen, dass der Safari alle 13 Sekunden alle System-Ressourcen an sich reißt.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich denke, der Kapitän hat auch so einiges zu bieten, weil wenn du erst mal siehst, wie viel schicker das User-Interface geworden ist.
Also ehrlich gesagt, mir ist das gar nicht aufgefallen. Ich hatte das Ding installiert, ein bisschen drin rumgeklickt, dachte mir, oh ja.
Wie kann man das nicht sehen?
Hab wieder zurückgespult.
Das sprang mich geradezu an, als ich das erste Mal auf seinem Bild schon geschaut hab.
Okay, dann muss ich ja wirklich doch noch auf Horst Demite gehen, damit ich dann, wenn ich auf El Capitan zwei Tage später update, den Relief auch spüre. Was sonst? Merke ich vielleicht gar nichts davon.
Was bei 10.10.4 noch neu ist, was eigentlich die dachten, dass es nur mit El Capitan kommt, ist Sie haben den Discovery Day wieder rausgeschmissen und haben ihn wieder durch DNS-Responder ersetzt und wie der John Gruber bei Sam Daring Fireboy ja mutmaßt oder munkelt oder wie auch immer, werden da wohl mit 300 Radartickets bei Apple geschlossen werden, die mit Netzwerk zu tun haben. Also das ganze WLAN-Problem, also ich glaube, alles, alle Netzwerkprobleme, die es gab.
Nur 300?
Mit jeweils 30.000 plus eins Kommentaren drin oder Duplik-Kits.
Das muss wirklich ein unfassbarer Fail gewesen sein.
Ja, also ich verstehe es auch nicht. Das habe ich schon vor, weiß nicht wann, das war vor einem halben Jahr oder einem dreiviertel Jahr gemerkt, und zwar mein Mac Pro zu Hause. Ging alle, wie war das? Hatte ich ja auch in der Sendung schon mehrmals erzählt, ging alle eine Stunde und 50 Minuten ging der an für 30 Sekunden und ging dann wieder aus. Bis dann, nachdem ganz viele Leute da das auch das Problem hatten und viele geforscht haben und dann rausgefunden haben, dass das Problem wohl der Discovery Demon ist und wenn man den durch den alten MDNS- Responder von Mountain Lion ersetzt, dass es dann weg ist das Problem und also ich weiß nicht, was die bei dem Discovery Demon so verkackt haben. Vom Namen her hörte sie sich erstmal gut an, so richtig Unix- mäßig, so ein Discovery Demon, so wie sich das gehört und der macht halt da so Sachen, aber irgendwie haben sie es wohl irgendwie auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Mein Tipp, das Ding kommt wieder.
Würde ich auch sagen.
Was? Discovery-D?
Ja. Und wenn sie nur den MDNS-Responder umbenennen?
Ja. Ja, ja. Ich schätze mal, ich meine, was gibt es von dem Teil Southcote eigentlich?
Vom MDNS-Responder, ja klar.
Vom Discovery-D?
Das weiß ich nicht, aber der MDNS-Responder kannst du doch auch unter Freeways benutzen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Versionen.
Es sind zwei verschiedene Programme.
Forks?
Ich war mir jetzt bloß nicht klar, ob Apple die auch im Southcote Released hat. Aber müsste eigentlich.
Das, was die da hier in OSX benutzen, ist bestimmt das Eigen-, also das nicht Open Source kann ich mir ja gut vorstellen. Der MDNS-Responder, den es bei Freeways hier gibt, ist ja so ein ganz kleines Tool, was nur eine Sache macht. Aber das ist schon auch der von Apple, also Ja, aber der macht ja nicht nur dieses Bonjur-Zeug. Naja, aber der Discovery-D macht ja nicht noch mehr?
Es ist das, was Bonjur macht.
Ich dachte, der macht noch mehr auf dem Mac.
Das MDNS-Responder in Version 561.1 runterladen, da bei opensource.apple.com Aber ich weiß nicht, welche Version die gerade haben.
Aber den Discovery, den ich...
Obwohl, den gab es ja schon bei Yosemite, so gesehen.
Ja, der ist jetzt seit einem Jahr draußen eigentlich. Also meine These, das ist jetzt wirklich ins Blaue hinein, war, dass sie aufgrund zukünftiger Erwägungen und nicht so sehr aktuell technischer Notwendigkeiten auf ein neues Prozessmodell umgestiegen sind. Weil sie der Meinung waren, dass man das Ding einfacher in der Zukunft erweitern kann und dass sie bei MDNS Responder in irgendeiner Form in so ein Dead-End reinlaufen, was sie gerne verhindern wollen und lieber früher als später da ein Redesign machen. Und dabei quasi erstmal nur, in Anführungsstrichen, die Funktionalität vom MDNS Responder nachbilden. Und dann, wenn das dann halt läuft, und davon gingen sie wohl aus, als sie Yosemite released haben, dass sie dann darauf die anderen Features nachbauen können. Und dann ist ihnen irgendwie aber unter realen Bedingungen dieses Teil einfach weggezwiebelt, weil sie unter Umständen irgendwas ganz Grundlegendes in diesem Code verkackt haben. Und dann hat das Team das irgendwie nicht gefixt bekommen. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwann gesagt, Scheiß drauf, wenn ihr noch ein halbes Jahr braucht, meinetwegen, aber mit so einem Kack können wir die Kisten nicht laufen lassen. Jetzt ballern wir wieder die alten Korken drauf und fixen da vielleicht noch ein, zwei Dinge, die im Discovery-D nachgetragen wurden und fertig ist die Laube. Sehr viel mehr Drama sehe ich dann nicht.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, gab es halt massive Probleme, besonders dann, wenn man eine Apple TV im Netzwerk hatte. Weil die scheinbar irgendwelches Zeug announced hat, was den Discovery-D total die Hutschnur halt hochgehen lassen.
Da lief halt vor allem selber Discovery-D drauf.
Ja, wahrscheinlich das auch. Keine Ahnung. Gab es ein Update zu Apple TV?
Es gibt laufende Updates für die Apple TV. Da gibt es alle Nase lang, die zeigen einem bloß die Version nicht an. Deswegen kann ich das jetzt nicht so beantworten, wann da was womit korreliert hat. Aber es würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern, wenn das letzten Endes dieselbe Software ist, weil das macht ja auch nichts anderes. Das ist ja auch nur ein OST. Oder ein iOS, was da draufläuft.
Ja, inzwischen ein iOS. Früher war es mal ein OSX.
Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so der große Unterschied. Also da läuft halt irgendwie ein Subsystem, was eben das macht und das ist klar. Kann auch sein, dass MDNS Responda nur unter OSX lief und Discovery D ihre Lösung war für iOS und das. Nee, das ist jetzt ein bisschen geraten. Egal, wie auch immer, alles ist weg. Und scheinbar ist das jetzt das Release, was Huckel installieren darf, damit er auch glücklich wird.
Also ich warte jetzt noch ein, zwei Tage und wenn dann nicht irgendwelche Hörer die Hände hochreißen, sagen, nein, bloß nicht, jetzt geht das nächste Subsystem nicht.
Ich hatte halt immer wieder Probleme mit Bluetooth und die gingen immer dadurch weg, dass man WLAN ausgeschaltet hat und wieder eingeschaltet hat. Was natürlich irgendwie super peinlich ist.
Ich werde auch tatsächlich mal wieder so einen richtigen Clean-Install dann machen, so richtig Ground Zero, was ich auch schon seit Langem...
Eine Tabel-Methode, ja.
Ja, habe ich sehr lang geschätzt, schon nicht mehr gemacht. Was war das? An drüber installieren.
Ach so, warte mal, kann das auch nicht sein, dass Discovery Day sich eben auch um Bluetooth und so weiter und diese ganzen anderen Subsysteme auch mit gekümmert hat.
Handover-Continuity, ich glaube.
Und MDNS-Responder halten nur um MDNS auf IP.
Du, keine Ahnung, vielleicht war Discovery Day auch nur die Apple-Portierung von System D.
Nee, das ist ja nun was ganz anderes.
Ja, aber ein ähnliches Problem fällt. Ja, was ist denn daraus geworden?
Das ist die neue Realität.
Der Weltstandard, der überall läuft auf allen Linux-Systemen. Ja, ist so.
Ich habe nur, das letzte, was ich gehört habe, war, dass sie sich alle fürchterlich drum geschnitten haben. Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist so ein bisschen Gamergate in Linux-Land.
Ja, es gibt da schon unterschiedliche Meinungen.
Die schweigen da schon immer noch.
Da gab es alles, was Gamergate auch hatte. Morddrohungen, volles Programm. Also das war auf jeden Fall genauso unschön. Und Tatsache ist, der Kram ist modern und alle verbreiteten Linux-Distributionen haben das jetzt. Fertig ist die Laube und es läuft immer noch. Kann so schlimm nicht gewesen sein.
Na ja, nachdem es sowieso über 500 gibt, werden da wahrscheinlich auch welche dabei sein, die nicht haben.
So, dann kommen wir zu anderen Bitkramen. Odi war ja letztes Mal nicht da. Deswegen darf er die nächsten Themen nochmal aufgreifen. Bitcode zum Beispiel. Mir ist ja später dann aufgefallen, dass dieser Name schon seit Februar oder März in der Welt war. Schlicht und ergreifend war das halt einfach Teil der Dokumentation von einem LLVM-Release. Das ist quasi in LLVM neu gewesen Anfang dieses Jahres. Ich habe mich irgendwie verguckt, aber so sah es aus. Ich habe einen Podcast gefunden, wo Bitcode ausführlich schon besprochen wurde im Februar oder März und verlinkt er halt auf die entsprechenden Dokumentationszerten. Die werden sicherlich nicht erst nachträglich eingetragen worden sein, zumal er eben auf einem sehr niedrigen Level darüber diskutiert war. Also auf einem hohen Level, was die Analyse betrifft und einem niedrigen Level, was die Details betrifft. Und ja, da gab es auch schon interessanterweise in den Podcasts diese Debatte, wozu man denn das gebrauchen könnte. Da ist mir dann auch irgendwie, nachdem ich mir kurz die Seite durchgelesen habe, klar geworden, was Bitcode genau ist. Und genau ist Bitcode ein Container-Format für diese Intermediate Representation Datenstruktur des LLVM. Also Bitcode ist nicht das Intermediate Representation Format, sondern es ist ein Container dafür, womit allerlei XML, halt noch Metadaten beschrieben werden, damit man eben mit diesem Intermediate-Kram das Richtige tun kann.
Da stehe ich sozusagen noch mal eine Ebene drüber. Da drin könnte man sagen, es ist dann der Bytecode. Ich würde das ja immer noch Bytecode nennen, weil man...
Es ist explizit nicht Bytecode, weil Bytecode ist halt was anderes. Also Bytecode ist ja so eine virtuelle Assembly-Language einer VM. Und der Bitcode ist halt ein Zwischenformat zum direkten Übersetzen in den finalen Maschinencode, wo ein Compiler dann wirklich quasi die maximal mögliche Optimierung vor der Laufzeit macht, während eine VM halt Laufzeit optimiert ist.
Also, so wie ich es verstanden habe, hat dieses Intermediate Representation Format im Prinzip unendlich viele Register. Und du kannst halt Prozessorunabhängig quasi Maschinencode darstellen, indem du sagst, die Operation ist von dem Register ins das Register. Und du kannst aber auf dieser Basis, kannst du dann halt so Optimierungen fahren, wie ich habe jetzt den Wert nach da verschoben, ich verschiebe den Wert nochmal nach da.
Da hat Chris Letten aber schon widersprochen. Da ist jemand auf der WWDC zu ihm hingegangen, hat gefragt, sag mal, ist das hier schon die Ankündigung, dass ihr eventuell dann auch einfach für eine andere Architektur halt den Intermediate Code kompilen könnt?
Dann hat der Apple-Mitarbeiter gesagt, nein.
Nein, er hat nicht nur nein gesagt, er hat gesagt, nein, in dem Augenblick ist eigentlich schon zu spät. Da sind Sachen wie Register und so ist dann in dem Code schon längst mit drin. Sondern ihr müsst eher dran denken an, jetzt hab ich's vergessen, scheiße.
An Optimierung, wenn man halt zum Beispiel noch weitere Register hinzufügt, noch ein Publikum von Register, etc.
Genau, wenn die Architektur erweitert wurde. Also bei Arm zum Beispiel gibt es ja irgendwie diese verschiedenen Instruction Sets, wenn neue Instructions dazukommen. So war es halt eher.
Hat er wirklich die Formulierung, da ist es schon zu spät, genannt?
Ich kann das nochmal direkt raus. Habt ihr das nicht auch in der letzten Sendung?
Ja, aber ich hab das aber so in Erinnerung, dass er nur gesagt hat, das ist nicht das, wofür wir es benutzen.
Nee, da stand so was along the lines, was eher für die Varianten von Architekturen ist als für... Das ist halt kein Cross-Compiler.
Na gut, aber welche Informationen fehlt denn in der Intermediate Representation, dass man sozusagen aus dem Code nicht 2% bedienen kann?
Jetzt sind wir wahrscheinlich alle nicht schlau genug, um diese Frage zu beantworten. Ich meine, du hast ja da aufgeschrieben so Sachen wie Big-Endian versus Little-Endian. Kann man aus dem Bitcode jetzt Big-Endian und Little-Endian kompilieren oder kann man es nicht? Keine Ahnung. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es geht, aber es kann auch sein, dass es an Kleinigkeiten einfach hängt, dass es nicht geht. Also schon allein das...
Wir können das ja vielleicht auch noch aufbauen, vielleicht geht es ja auch noch nicht, wer weiß.
Und 32-bit, 64-bit kann halt auch sein, dass es nicht geht, mal so eben. Aber ich kann mir halt durchaus vorstellen, dass du so was machst, wie du klickst dir deinen Prozessor zusammen, wie du es halt so machst in der Simulation. Wir wollen jetzt ein neues Instruction Set bauen und der hat so und so viel Register und der hat so und so lange Cashlines und jetzt nehmen wir mal den gesamten Bitcode, den wir da haben, und kompilieren ihn dann mal auf die Simulation und gucken, ob das schneller ist.
Also, ja, ist hier aus dem Quot irgendwie.
Machst du mal einen Link?
Ähm, ja, hier und da und schwupp und dann, da kannst du mal klicken und dann kannst du mal reinzoomen. Ja, der Text ist irgendwie sehr klein.
Klicken Sie den Link jetzt.
Ja, du bist ja jetzt der Jockey.
Ja, ich weiß.
Und dann so der obere Paragraf da, genau.
He wasn't surrounded by adoring crowds.
My hopes for return to Big Endian are dashed. Das kann natürlich sein, dass du wirklich dann auf Little Endian festgelegt bist, wenn du mal nach Little Endian kompilieren wirst. Ja, was auch immer das bedeutet. Also er sagt halt nicht, wir können es jetzt für einen Prozessor mit 32 Register kompilieren, aber nicht für einen mit 16 oder 4.
Ja.
Also meine Idee war ja auch, dass der Intel nach Arm Switch für einen MacBook eher so, das dachte ich so, das geht damit auch schon mal nicht.
Aber ich meine, die reden ja auch in keiner Silbe irgendwo von Cross-Compiling dadurch. Und das wäre es doch, wenn du auf verschiedene Architekturen mit irgendwie einem Fingerschnipp kommen könntest.
Na ja gut, auf der anderen Seite ist es halt so, wenn du jetzt ein neues Backend für einen neuen Prozessor für die LLVM Toolchain machst, musst du dann dem Frontend sagen, mach mal dieses und jenes nicht, weil sonst kann es nicht kompilieren. Das kann ja nun auch nicht sein.
Ja gut, also ich meine, was sie auf jeden Fall mit diesem Bitcode erhalten, ist halt einerseits die Möglichkeit, Code nachträglich zu optimieren, ohne dass die Programmierer etwas dazu tun, weil einfach dieser letzte Schritt nicht mehr beim Developer stattfindet, sondern eben im App Store. Und sie können im Prinzip auch dadurch, wenn sie einen neuen Prozessor rausbringen, der ein neues Feature hat, die alten Instruktionen, die sie gar nicht mehr unterstützen wollen, weil sie dafür jetzt viel tollere haben, auch rausschmeißen, weil sie kein Legacy mehr unterstützen müssen. Und das finde ich eigentlich eine sehr interessante Freiheit. Wir müssen nicht erst so einen großen Architecture Change einleiten, wie das jetzt mit der 64-Bit-Plattform bei ARM war, also der ja nicht nur eine Änderung von 32 auf 64 war, sondern sie haben ja auch den kompletten Instruktionssatz überarbeitet. Das ist ja sozusagen ein komplett neues Ding gewesen. Und im Prinzip könnte eine neue Watch jetzt einen Prozessor verwenden, der eben zwar immer noch in derselben Familie ist, aber eben sehr advanced mit sehr vielen neuen Instruktionen, die unter Umständen auch genau ihnen in die Wallet spielen, weil sie damit irgendwas sehr viel besser optimieren können im Bezug auf Battery Life oder was auch immer. Und sie können halt den ganzen anderen Schnaß komplett rausschmeißen und sind in der Lage, den vollständigen existierenden Programmcode von Third Party darauf zum Laufen zu bringen.
Also, so wie ich die Sache sehe, gibt es halt irgendwie drei Sachen, wo du optimieren willst. Das eine ist die Anzahl der Register. Das zweite ist deine Cash-Struktur, so First Level, Second Level Cash. Und das dritte sind halt esoterische Instruktionen. Also, hast du jetzt, ja, du hast halt eine Instruktion, die macht halt sonst was. Und dann gibt es immer das Trade-off, lohnt es sich jetzt, eine Instruktion zu haben, die die Sache schnell macht? Oder habe ich lieber irgendwie drei Instruktionen, die ungefähr das machen, aber es sind halt drei. Und ich glaube, dass du solche Sachen mit schon viel besser feintunen kannst, wenn du vorher weißt, egal wie ich das jetzt mache, ich kann das hinterher immer optimalen Code dafür generieren, weil ich habe dieses Zwischenformat. Also, keine Ahnung. Naja, wir werden es sehen. Aber es ist interessant, dass sie es vor allen Dingen für die Watch erst mal machen. Ja, aber für iOS ist es optionell. Also, ich kann für iOS 9, SDK, also ist es angekündigt, kann ich eine App einreichen und muss nicht Bitcode anhaben. Wenn ich aber eine WatchOS 2 App einreiche, muss sie Bitcode haben. Also, so habe ich jetzt der Platform State of the Union verstanden.
Okay, dann habe ich irgendwas anders verstanden. Ich dachte, sie machen es generell, dass alles Bitcode sein muss.
Nein, nein, nein, für iOS ist es nach wie vor optional, aber für WatchOS ist es verpflichtend.
Okay, aber der Antrieb ist da auf jeden Fall ein ähnlicher, klar. Schon enorm, ja.
Ja gut, ich meine, sie haben jetzt mit dem 64-Bit-Arm ja jetzt erstmal einen Prozessor eingeführt, der ganz fit ist. Ich glaube, da müssen sie jetzt erstmal erstmal nicht weiter optimieren. Insofern, aber wer weiß, was Apple so tut, um sich die Android-Konkurrenz zu im Hals zu halten, so einiges.
Vielleicht kommen sie ja irgendwann auch mit CPUs, wo man sich Feature freischalten kann.
Mit In-App-Purchases.
Das ist not the Apple way. Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Eigentlich nicht, ja.
Also ich habe jetzt auch schon mal durch das eine oder andere Dokument geschaut zum Thema LLVM-Bitcode und so wie ich das hier alles aus diesen ganzen Grafiken rauslese. Ich finde einfach nichts, wo steht, dass das wirklich schon Prozessorspezifisch ist. Weil bei LLVM ist es tatsächlich dreistufig. Du hast irgendwie das Frontend, das erzeugt LLVM-IR. Dann kommt der Optimizer, der aus dem IR auch IR macht. Und dann kommt das Backend, was es halt in den eigentlichen Machine Code übersetzt.
Ja, so hatte ich das auch verstanden.
Genau, aber wenn Bitcode IR ist, dann ist es ja der IR auf jeden Fall in der Mitte.
Auch nach der Optimierung. Es sei denn, es ist nicht ganz so, wie es dargestellt wird und nicht alle Optimierer funktionieren mit allen Backends. Das kann ja auch sein.
Und es gibt auch mehrstufige Optimierungen.
Also da würde ich jetzt mal nicht zu viel draufgeben, weil sowas natürlich in der Dokumentation erstmal vereinfacht dargestellt wird. Aber die Welt ist meistens komplexer.
Na gut, also wir verlinken mal hier so ein paar Dokumente und unsere schlauen Hörer können dann das selber überprüfen und in den Kommentaren entsprechend besser wisserisch aktiv werden. Genau. Womit machen wir weiter? Na, Hoddy.
Gleich mal Swift 2.
Heute ist die Body Show.
Ich war zweimal nicht da.
Letztes Mal war die Huckel-Show. Ich stehe mal ein bisschen auf.
Ich hör, dass es die Watch gesagt hat.
Swift 2.
Wie bitte?
Hat dir das die Watch gesagt, dass du aufstehen musst?
Nee, sagt die Watch einem, dass man aufstehen soll?
Ja, alle Stunden soll man aufstehen.
Aber ihr seid noch gar nicht aufgestanden.
Das ist so lustig. Die Watch hat auch noch nichts gesagt.
Mir ist das Thema aber schon zwei Stunden auf.
Ich kann mit der Watch halt auch viel länger sitzen.
Ich musste die hier die ganze Zeit laden, weil sie sitzen. Ich war neulich bei so einer Konferenz. Da hatten auch einige schon die Watch. Wenn sie sich alle gleichzeitig zum Talk hinsetzen, dann geht die Watch auch bei allen gleichzeitig an. So nach der Art, jetzt ist die Stunde um, jetzt müsst ihr alle aufstehen. Man kriegt diese Meldung und dann guckt man in die Runde und Leute heben die Hand. Das ist sehr lustig anzugucken.
Das müssen sie noch mal ein bisschen randomisieren, Leute.
Ist ja auch nervig, wenn sie alle einzeln aufstehen. Das ist doch besser, alle gemeinsam kurz. Wir machen jetzt mal fünf Minuten Pause gleichzeitig. Okay, jetzt aber.
Swift 2. Es gibt hier eine Menge Kleinkramen, auf denen will ich eigentlich gar nicht so richtig eingehen. So was wie Availability, dass man fragen kann, welche Systemversion unterstütze ich denn so, wofür man früher IFDEV verwendet hat. Interessant fand ich das Guard, Let Else. Es gibt ja diese Optionals in Swift, die manchmal ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen verbreiten. Also ein Typ kann entweder ein garantierter Typ sein, dann hat das Ding immer einen Wert, oder es kann ein Optional sein, dann hat es entweder einen Wert oder ist nil. Und wenn es ein Optional ist, dann muss man es aber in vielen Fällen erstmal quasi anoptionalisieren, so unboxen, damit man dann tatsächlich einen Wert hat. Aber wenn halt kein Wert hat, dann macht man was anderes. Und da gibt es halt dieses If-Led, Dings gleich Dings, dann, wenn es zutrifft, ok, da ist ein Wert drin, dann kann ich was tun, mit dem jetzt nicht mehr Optional Wert und ansonsten so.
Da fand ich auch ein bisschen viel Code dafür, dass es, wenn es ein cooles Feature ist und es macht ja Sinn, diese Optionals, dann will man ja eigentlich auch oft benutzen. Und dafür war es aber wieder sehr viel Boilerplate, dass du den ganzen Code siehst, dann kannst du das nicht mehr lesen.
Und jetzt haben sie endlich ein Einsehen gehabt für die Leute, die gerne Early Exits machen. Also wenn das gleich nill, dann return. Wenn das gleich nill, dann return. Und dafür gibt es jetzt das Guard Let Else. Also es liest sich erstmal ein bisschen komisch, aber du kannst quasi einen Optional auspacken. Und wenn es nicht ausgepackt wird, nur dann wird der Block hinter dem Else ausgeführt und du kannst einen Return machen oder so. Fand ich ganz lustig, abgesehen davon, dass es sich komisch liest. So, und dann die eigentliche Neuigkeit meiner, ja gut, Protocol Extensions ist jetzt auch nicht so wichtig. Die eigentliche Neuigkeit meiner Meinung nach ist das Error Handling. Und zwar sieht es jetzt auch bei Switft sehr stark nach dem aus, was woanders Exceptions sind. Aber erstens, es sind keine Exceptions, weil in den meisten Programmiersprachen ist der Exception-Zweig eine Größenordnung langsamer als der normale Zweig. Also wenn eine Exception geworfen wird, dann macht er irgendwie Stack Unrolling und haste nicht gesehen. Und lauter Kram, der irgendwie die Sache langsam macht.
Stack Trace sammeln und formatieren.
Genau, und bei Switft ist es aber so, dass es eigentlich nur eine Kurznotation ist dafür, dass man eine Error-Variable per Referenz übergibt, die hinterher gefüllt ist. So, und was ich das eigentlich Interessante daran finde, ist, du hast ja so normalerweise, wenn man jetzt C++ anguckt oder Java oder so, dann hast du halt ein Try-Catch-Finally. Das heißt, du hast drei funktionelle Blöcke. Das erste ist das Try. Du versuchst etwas zu tun, was schiefgehen kann. Dann machst du einen Catch. Du fängst einen Fehler, wenn er denn auftritt. Und das Letzte ist das Finally. Du machst Aufräumarbeiten, die auf jeden Fall stattfinden müssen. Das Dumme ist nur, das ist immer in einem Konstrukt. Und was Apple jetzt gemacht hat, und das ist wirklich genial, ist, diese drei Dinge in Einzelkonstrukte aufzulösen. Also das Try, das Catch und das quasi Finally sind immer unabhängig voneinander. Du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel mit diesem Finally...
Und Pro Funktionen aber nur einmal erlaubt, Ravie.
Ne, das Ding ist folgende. Wenn eine Funktion einen Error schmeißen kann, dann musst du sie als Throws deklarieren. Und wenn aber da irgendwie ein Error rausfallen kann und du die nicht als Throws deklariert hast, dann ist es ein Compilerfehler. Und wenn eine Funktion einen Fehler schmeißen kann, dann musst du sie mit Try aufrufen. Wenn du das nicht tust, ist das auch ein Compilerfehler.
Du musst signalisieren, dass du weißt, dass hier ein entsprechender Fehler erzeugt werden kann.
Genau. Wenn du keinen Catch machst, dann muss die Funktion, die die Throws-Funktion aufruft, auch eine Throws-Funktion sein, weil der Fehler ja weitergeworfen wird.
Das klingt ja aus diesen Sprachen, aus denen ich so komme. Der Quatsch steht dazwischen. Das gibt es doch gar nicht.
Nein, wenn eine Funktion...
Macht einfach weiter, aber beschwert sich bei einer. Das ist auch richtig.
Manchmal weiter.
Ich sage nichts.
Du hast den Huckel gerade abgeschnitten.
Aber nein, macht mal weiter. Ich spreche jetzt bei euch dazwischen.
Roddy war doch noch gar nicht fertig.
Willst du mich verarschen?
Also, wenn er nicht fertig war, warum quatsche denn dazwischen? Ihr seid jetzt alle raus, ich sehe schon.
Oh Gott, das war's.
Also, Catch ist als Du Catch. Also, man hat eine Du mit Klammer, und da sind Try-Funktionen drin. Und wenn irgendeine schmeißt, kommst du direkt ins Catch. Wenn du das nicht fängst, fällt der Error weiter in die aufrufende Funktion. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das jetzt so ohne Code vor Augen siehst.
Ja, wobei kann ich dir noch folgen.
So, und das Interessante, das Finally wird durch ein Kommando namens Defur abgebildet. Das Interessante ist, du kannst Defur benutzen ohne Try-Catch. Das Beispiel, das sie hier haben, ist, let File gleich Open File Name und danach machen sie Defur Close File. Und das Lustige ist, dass alle Defur Blocks werden nach dem Rausgehen aus der Funktion abgearbeitet. Und zwar der, der zuletzt eingefüllt wurde als erstes. Du kannst ja beliebig viele Defur Blocks einfüllen. So eine Art Go-to-Fail quasi. Und dadurch kannst du halt die Strukturen, die du in einer Funktion aufgebaut hast, alle wieder richtig rum abbauen.
Das heißt, man schiebt quasi diese ganzen Aufräumfunktionen auf so einen Stack, die danach alle abgearbeitet werden?
Genau, nach dem Return. Noch in der Funktion.
Was gefiel dir jetzt nicht dran? Huckel, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht mehr zugehört.
Er hat gesagt, in den Sprachen, die er kennt, und dann wurde er abgerissen.
Also im Vergleich dazu klingt das auf jeden Fall nach unglaublich viel Ringeltanz mit Anfassen und Wirrwarr und Exzepte.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nicht ganz. Der Error, den du schmeißt, ist immer ein I-Namen. Das ist auch sehr interessant, weil nämlich der Compiler dann darüber sinnieren kann, ob du tatsächlich alle möglichen Fehlerfälle gehändelt hast. Und wenn du einen Fehlerfall nicht händelst, ist es immer ein Compiler Error.
Ja, aber also erstmal hast du ja irgendwie gemeint, wenn eine Funktion einen Fehler haben kann, kann ich prinzipiell erstmal jede Funktion Fehler haben?
Na ja, eine Funktion hat dann Fehler, wenn sie einen Fehler schmeißt.
Also nur wenn du explizit du selber throwest?
Wenn ich sage Throw Error Type, dann ist es ein Fehler, den die Funktion schmeißt.
Und dann musst du dich um die ganze Call-Chain kümmern?
Oder ich rufe eine Funktion auf, die einen Fehler schmeißt. Aber die kann ich nur mit Try aufrufen, also es ist immer klar, ob eine Funktion einen Fehler schmeißt oder nicht. Weil wenn ich kein Try davor schon mal schreibe und die Funktion kann einen Fehler fangen, ist es sofort ein Compiler Error.
Meine Frage vorhin war ja, läuft das nicht darauf hinaus, dass im Prinzip ein richtiges, gutes Switft-Programm alles mit 3 aufgerufen wird, dass 3 überall davor steht, weil man eigentlich immer irgendwie Fehler haben will? Oder ist das...
So in etwa in die Richtung geht mein unverständliches Gucken auch, weil es klingt so ein bisschen...
Was war das Brainfuck, wo man irgendwie immer vor jede Zeit noch Please Do davor schreiben muss, damit das überhaupt irgendwas macht?
Nein, Brainfuck war diese Sprache, die nur aus neuen Zeichen besteht.
Ja, nee, es gab noch eine andere Sprache, da muss man irgendwie immer Please Do davor schreiben. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die heißt.
Aber was machst du denn mit den anderen Fehlern, also an die du nicht gedacht hast?
Was sind denn andere Fehler?
Interkei.
Na, irgendwelche Sachen, die du jetzt halt nicht so aktiv vorhergesehen hast, die vielleicht aber auch schiefgehen können.
Naja, es gibt halt noch Laufzeitfehler, die du nicht fangen kannst, da stürzt das Programm ab. Division by Zero ist ein Laufzeitfehler, der ist halt...
Na gut, das wäre jetzt vielleicht noch der Dürfste von allen, aber...
Ja, oder du iterierst über eine Array-Grenze hinweg, ist auch ein Laufzeitfehler.
Und das nimmt man dann aber einfach so hin?
Das geht an Switft gar nicht.
Was? Natürlich. Du kannst natürlich ein Array mit 5 Werten befüllen und sagen, gib mir...
Das Sechste.
Das Sechste. Das kannst du machen.
Aber der wird ja gefangen. Als Exception. Nicht so wie ein C, der einfach passiert.
Exceptions gibt es ja nicht.
Im Gegensatz zu C lässt er dich nicht.
Also ist das... Also in manchen Sprachen gibt es das ja auch nicht als Exceptions. Da ist ja dann das mit diesem Throw und Catch ist ja eigentlich nur ein verstecktes Go-To, wo man halt so den ganzen Call-Stack halt so mal komplett wieder... Also wo man halt so...
Ja, ja, ich weiß, das ist auch etwas...
Zum Beispiel in einer tiefen Rekursion mal ganz eloquent ganz wieder schnell rausspringen kann. Also je nachdem, wie schnell das mit dem Accept-Handling und so weiter oder diesem Throw-Cancel...
Also sie versprechen einem, dass es ein normales Return aus der Funktion ist und dass es nicht langsamer ist als ein normales... Ja, als ein normales Return. Ja, ein Return aus der Funktion halt, ne?
Na ja, da gibt's ja auch...
Sie organisieren halt das Error-Management auf Compiler-Level. Das ist sozusagen ein Sprachfeature, das dir ein sicheres Programmieren erlaubt, was aber keinen oder kaum einen Einfluss auf den Speed hat.
Ja, also ist es so, unter Coco gibts halt dieses NSError-Objekt, wo du viele Funktionen kannst du halt aufrufen und dann ist halt eins... Einer der Aufrufparameter ist halt quasi so ein doppelter Pointer auf ein NSError-Objekt. Und du kriegst halt... Ja, ne, du kriegst halt ein Ergebnis zurück oder nil und dann ist dein Error-Objekt ausgefüllt, was halt relativ viel Boilerplate-Code ist, aber relativ gut funktioniert auch. Wenn man aber ein Thread hat, ja. Wenn du mehrere... Kannst das Error-Objekt auch an einem anderen Thread weiterleichen. Da hast du einen Vorteil zu einem...
Ja, okay, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Zu einer Exception, wo das halt nicht geht, weil die fällt halt einfach irgendwo raus. Also das geht schon.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie über Error-Management nachgedacht. Das ist ja auch schon mal sehr schön, weil das war ja am Anfang irgendwie überhaupt nicht da. Und man fragte sich halt, ob sie sozusagen davon ausgehen, dass diese Programme gar keine Fehler mehr enthalten. Weil wenn man sie hier nicht händeln kann, dann...
Es ist halt diese alte Diskussion zwischen Programmierfehlern, die halt, wie soll ich sagen, katastrophal sind und die auch zur Laufzeit nicht sinnvoll zu händeln sind. Und Fällen, wo Dinge halt nicht so laufen, wie man sie sich vorstellt, also Happy Path, aber die nicht katastrophal sind. Also wenn eine Datei nicht da ist und ich versuche, sie zu öffnen, das ist nicht katastrophal.
Ja, und denkst du, dass jetzt sozusagen Switft für beide Fälle was im Store hat oder nur für den Katastrophenfall?
Nein, nicht Katastrophenfall. Wenn du durch Null teilst, dann hast du dich Null geteilt, dann hast du einen Fehler gemacht.
Dann kriegst du Infinity als Resultat.
Dann kriegst du norther number, aber das ist noch mal ein anderes Thema.
Das kann ja auch eine Botschaft sein.
Norther number kann eine Botschaft sein, ja.
Nö, auch so war es. Ich meine, wenn du so einen User-Input hast und der User möchte das teilen, dann kannst du das ja zur Kenntnis nehmen, dass der User das wollte und ihm dann sagen, dass es halt so nicht geht. Aber da muss man ja nicht gleich das ganze Programm beenden.
Wie auch immer.
So sehe ich das. Und Huckel?
Naja, ich bin mir immer noch nicht so ganz sicher, welche Spielart das denn jetzt wirklich ist. Weil, wie gesagt, manche Programmiersprachen benutzen das halt eigentlich so als Go-Tour-Ersatz. Also das heißt dann sowas wie Try Catch und so, aber eigentlich ist es auch dafür da, also es wird auch dafür missbraucht, sozusagen normale Code-Pfade abzubilden, um mal eben aus irgendeiner tiefen Rekursion oder so wieder rauszuspringen. Und dann gibt es halt auch die Kandidaten, die nehmen das halt wirklich so als wirkliches Error-Handling, sagen wir mal, wahr. Und dann gibt es noch Go. Die machen halt gar keins auch, glaube ich. Da muss man sich alles selber testen.
Ja, da gibt es halt Panic. Da heißt die Exception halt so, wie sie eigentlich eigentlich heißen müsste, Panic.
Bei Ruby heißt das ja Begin, Rescue und Ensure. Da gibt es so ein tolles Video, wo einer so total abgeht und meint so, ja, irgendwie try und dann catch me Java, catch me, sounds so weak, where Ruby starts a rescue mission.
Naja, die eigentlich interessante Sache da dran finde ich halt wirklich, dass du dieses Abarbeiten des Final Blocks von dem Try-Catch löst.
Das kann man zum Beispiel, wenn ich mich rechnen sind, ist das bei Ruby so, du kannst halt in jede Funktion halt Rescue und auch einen Ensure mit reinhängen. Und ich glaube, wenn du nur einen Ensure mit reinhängst, dann wird das halt einfach auch immer sozusagen mit ausgeführt. Also es wird halt einfach immer, wenn du das Ensure reinmachst, das kommt immer sozusagen nochmal zum Schluss. Und bei Erlang, das wäre dann nochmal der nächste, die nächste Spielart von Errahending, da ist ja dieses Let it Crash, wo du sowieso alles so Actors hast und du kannst halt auch genau sagen, ok, wenn das crash, dann kannst du auch noch so Restart-Strategies und so festlegen, wo dann sagst du, ok, pass auf, probier es jetzt nochmal dreimal im Abstand von so und so viel Sekunden, wenn es dann nicht ist, dann mach wirklich aus.
Ja, aber Actor-Based ist halt Swift und Coco halt einfach noch nicht, oder weiß nicht, ob es das je sein wird, aber da ist Apple nicht an der Stelle. Also ich fände das auch schön, aber in einem normalen Coco-Programm passiert viel zu viel auf Mainthread.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie dahin wollen. Das ist schon eine bewusste Entscheidung für die niedrige Systemebene. Und hier sozusagen einen Fehlerbehandlungskonstrukt aufzurufen, was sich dort auf einem niedrigen Level abspielt, aber zumindest so viele High-Level-Konzepte ermöglicht, dass man überhaupt erst mal anfängt, sein Programm nach solchen Ereignissen zu strukturieren. Weil das, was du am Anfang gesagt hast, wenn überhaupt ein Fehler gemeldet wird von einer Funktion, dann ist auch die aufrufende Funktion auf einmal in der Pflicht, das richtig zu benutzen. Das ist ja auch eine Methode, Error-Management auch quasi in den Programmen zu verankern. Und wenn sich das dann irgendwie auch alles noch weiter durchleitet, dann hast du da ohne irgendwie Objektorientierung und Delegation und so einen Kram im Prinzip einen vergleichbaren Mechanismus. Und dann drücken quasi die Libraries dieses Fehler-Management ja auch in die Apps rein.
Und der Compiler sorgt dafür, dass du es auch wirklich benutzt, weiter reißt und dass du dich kümmerst.
Und dass da Fehler deklariert werden können, die man dann nicht missachten darf. Oder für die man zumindest einen Fall bereitstellen muss, wie man dann damit umgeht, wenn er auftritt. Und das sind ja alles so Elemente, die man in so einem Simple Programming-Environment nicht hat.
Und übrigens, Catch hat Pattern-Matching. Das ist auch ganz interessant.
Pattern-Matching auf was?
Naja, auf den Fehler.
Ja, aber was für ein Pattern?
Pattern-Matching im Allgemeinen halt.
Ja, was, auf den String oder auf Daten?
Nein, ein Fehler ist ja ein Enum. Und ein Enum kann aber noch weitere Associated Values haben. So, also, was weiß ich, wenn jetzt die Tage...
Ist noch ein bisschen Fairy Dust draufgesprinklt auf den Integer.
Ja, nein, du kannst halt...
Enum ist ein Enhanced Number.
Singleton Factory.
Die haben ja Enums, die keine Numbers sind. Du kannst einfach den Namen hinschreiben und das war's dann.
Nein, wenn du jetzt die Tage der Woche als Enum ausdrücken würdest, hättest du sieben Enum-Values und dann hättest du den Sonntag und dann könnte der Sonntag aber noch verkaufsoffen sein oder nicht. So. Und dann kannst du halt ein Pattern-Matching machen, wie Catch Sonntag ist und ist verkaufsoffen, dann machte es...
Weil man den Enums auf Functions anhängen kann, richtig? Oder wie war das?
Na ja, sogenannte Associated Values eben.
Da wird es halt immer sehr komplex, dann steigt man ein bisschen aus, immer noch die Douglas, weil die rattern da so schnell durch. Man müsste echt immer anhalten und...
Na ja, also Swift 2 ist da und... Nee, da ist es noch nicht so richtig. Da ist auch alles noch Beta.
Das ist nicht Swift 2, das ist Swift 1.2.
Nein, mit Xcode 7 Beta gibt es jetzt Swift 2.0 und seit der zweiten Beta funktioniert es auch.
Aber bei 6,4, was gestern kam, Xcode 6.4, für das 10.10.4 kam Swift 1.2.
Das gibt es ja auch schon eine Weile.
Ja, aber ist das doch jetzt rausgekommen?
Da steht nur, dass es drin ist, aber es war auch schon vorher drin.
Ach so, und das Objective-C jetzt irgendwie noch Generics bekommen hat, habt ihr darüber letztes Mal schon gesprochen?
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Also du kannst jetzt Generics in Objective-C benutzen.
Damit es besser mit Swift austauschbar ist, weil Swift so viele Features auch mit den Optionals hat.
Wir fangen jetzt an, die Swift-Features in Objective-C nachzurüsten, damit die Leute endlich wirklich umsteigen.
Ja, weil sie auch ihre eigenen Frameworks damit nachrüsten, damit es wiederum einfacher hat. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz sinnvoll. Kommen wir jetzt zu einer anderen Programmiersprache, die eben schon viel... Da geht es um ein kleines Knacken durchs Universum.
Genau, die andere Programmiersprache, die es schon seit über 20 Jahren gibt und mir das Programmierleben immer wieder erfreut, ist Erlang. Da haben sich ja in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen auch die Rubikommunity so ein bisschen eingenistet, also Teile davon, zumindest die, die ordentlich was wuppen. Da gab es ja den Josef Walim, der ja diese rubiartige Sünde hat, die er für Erlang gebaut hat, namens Elixir. Das war am Anfang ja nur so ein Spielprojekt und mittlerweile meint er das aber ziemlich ernst und ist auch auf den ganzen Konferenzen und auch mit den ganzen Erlang-Entwicklern per Du. Und wird auch eingeladen und für die, die es nicht wissen, dass Elixir halt so eine Ruby-Eske-Sündags, aber kompilert halt, also es ist nur ein Präprozessor im Wesentlichen oder kompilert in den selben Bitcode. Also man kann auch einfach Erlang-Bitcode mit da drin benutzen.
Das ist so wie mit Scala und Java.
Ja, so in etwa würde ich sagen. Also das sind halt ein paar... Genau, das auf jeden Fall.
Naja eben, das ist ja der Sinn der Sache. Oder ist es wirklich nur eine andere Syntax für exakt die selbe Art von Programmieren?
Also ich bilde mir ein, dass es eigentlich nur... In Erlang heißt es ja Pass Transforms. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich ein Präprozessor vom Compiler. Am Ende kommt da ganz stinknormaler Erlang Bitcode raus sozusagen.
Also könntest du das auch wieder in Erlang Syntax... Also könnte man ein LXR-Programm auf Sourcecode-Level in Erlang übersetzen? Oder sind da Konstrukte drin, die es so in Erlang nicht gibt?
Eigentlich nicht, nein. Letztendlich müsste das alles schon in Erlang implementiert sein. Aber bei Erlang gibt es ja so eine Zwischenebene, wie man da auch eigene Features in die VM mit reinkriegt. Also welchem Stand das jetzt bei LXR genau ist, kann ich dir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht 100%ig sagen. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es so, du kannst jedes Erlang-Modul in LXR benutzen. Und das, was hinten rauskommt beim Compilen, ist halt dieses Beam-File, dieser Binary.
Ja, halt der Bitcode, der Erlang vor allem.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, seitdem die da fleißig wirbeln und eben auch so ein bisschen irgendwie Präsenz gezeigt haben, tut sich auch beim Erlang-Team selber so ein bisschen, da bewegt sich irgendwie plötzlich mal wieder was, wo sich lange Zeit nicht viel bewegt hat. Also mit OTP 17 haben sie jetzt ja tatsächlich Hashmaps auch eingeführt. Das war ja...
OTP heißt was?
Open Telekom Platform, glaube ich, ne? Also es ist halt einfach nur ein Marketing-Name. Es ist am Ende Erlang, aber so nennen die ihre Releases.
So heißt die Library, glaube ich, die dazu stand, als sie gehört.
Ja, nee, es ist am Ende Marketing gewesen.
Das ist halt bei Ericsson entstanden. Das war sozusagen neben der Core-Language das erste Framework, mit dem man seine Apps ordentlich strukturieren kann. Und da ging es halt um die Telekom-Industrie.
Aber das war wirklich so, dass einer der Manager gesagt hat, so, ja Erlang, da kann sich keiner drunter was vorstellen. Wir nennen das jetzt Open Telekom Platform. Und am Ende, alle haben sich so an den Kopf gefasst, so, äh, äh.
Genau, und jetzt sitze ich da und muss fragen, was OTP ist, weil Erlang ist voll klar.
Ja, ist da noch keine andere Übersetzung für OTP eingefallen, die irgendwie auch Sinn macht?
Genau, das ist jetzt, also das ist wirklich das geringste Problem, sagen wir mal. Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, haben sie ja Hashmaps eingeführt und es gab da, bei Erlang ist übrigens ganz witzig, so wie die neuen Features reinkommen, da gibt es solche Proposals auch, so ähnlich wie ein bisschen RFC, so Request for Comment. Kann auch jeder welche einreichen und die werden halt auch regelmäßig so von Erlang, von Ericsson sozusagen durchgegangen und die werden dann immer so ein bisschen weiter gefiltert und die vielversprechendsten irgendwann... Na ja, von dem Erlang-Team letztendlich, ne?
Ja, das hat ja mit Ericsson alles nichts mehr zu tun.
Ja, Ericsson hat da schon noch viel Finger drin.
Ja, also Ericsson ist da involviert, aber das eigentliche Language-Development findet nicht bei Ericsson statt.
Ja, aber wenn du zur Erlang User Conference nach Stockholm fährst, dann finden die Workshops und so alle bei Ericsson statt und du weißt, du merkst einfach, dass...
Dass das das zu Hause ist, aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass die Ericsson-Leute ihr Erlang-Team entlassen haben und weggeschickt haben und gesagt haben, nehmt euren Scheiß mit, den wollen wir nie wieder sehen.
Das haben sie auch revidiert wieder, ja.
Genau, dann sind sie mit ihren Java-Projekten kolossal gescheitert und haben dann sozusagen klein-laut die wieder eingeladen.
Aber das ist halt immer noch eine DNA trotz all dem drin. Anyway, auf jeden Fall diese Proposals, eine davon war halt, ja, wie sieht es denn aus mit Hashmaps, ne? Und es wurde schon lange, lange, lange sich gewünscht. Aber es gab auch gute Gründe, warum sie das nicht eingebaut haben, weil bei Erlang ist ja ein cooles Feature dieses Pattern-Matching. Und weil du gerade meintest, ja, was denn? Da kann man halt auf alles Pattern-Matching, was in der Sprache ist, und halt auch ziemlich cool und flexibel. Und ein Problem, was wir halt hatten, war, ja, wenn wir jetzt Hashmaps einbauen, dann hat das halt gewisse Implikationen, also auf viele Zwischenteile der Sprache einfach. Und deswegen haben sie lange überlegt, wie sie das halt implementieren können, so dass Pattern-Matching auch weiterhin geht, auch auf Hashmaps, ohne Performance einboosten und so weiter. Und irgendwann haben sie dann halt sich mal rausgewagt und die erste Implementierung in Version 16 reingebracht und jetzt in Erlang 18 oder R18B0, wie es offiziell heißt. Da haben sie jetzt auch noch mal weiter Performance-mäßig dran geschraubt und Feature-mäßig dran geschraubt. Jetzt sind Hashmaps tatsächlich in Erlang Realität. Jahrzehntelang haben die Leute darauf gewartet.
Ja, aber es war doch auch in der 16 schon Realität.
Achso, haben sie es da wirklich in 16? War es nicht erst in 17?
Es kann auch 17 gewesen sein. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, aber es ist jetzt sozusagen nicht als Brand New.
Nein, genau. In R18 haben sie im Wesentlichen, sie haben ja in diesem Proposal schon die ganze Syntax durchdekliniert, was sie am Ende haben wollen. In R17 haben sie halt, sagen wir mal, eine Minimal Viable Version davon implementiert. Also da war der Syntax, die ganzen Shortcuts und Convenience Methods waren da halt noch nicht drin. Und in R18 haben sie jetzt nicht nur die Performance deutlich verbessert für größere Hashmaps, sondern eben auch mehr von diesen Syntax-Versprechen und Convenience Methods mal bewahrheitet sozusagen.
Ist das jetzt sozusagen schon in einem finalen Zustand und das Thema ist jetzt durch?
Ja, die Leute seit R17 benutzen das schon alle. Also in den ganzen Libraries, wo es Sinn macht, zum Beispiel die Jason Libraries, Jason-Parser Libraries, die haben ja das alles entweder in Prop-Lists gemacht oder in... da gibt es auch... es gab schon Binary Dicts und so weiter, aber das war immer ein Megaschmerz und das war einfach... alle haben so gesagt so... Bitte, erlöst uns. Und sobald R17 draußen war, hat schon die ganzen Jason Libraries haben sofort gleich das Flag eingeführt. Wenn du Jason willst, bitte... Quatsche, wenn du Hashmaps willst, bitte schön.
Das ist jetzt bestimmt wieder so ein Teil unserer Sendung, wo irgendwie der Anteil von Hörern, denen jetzt gerade so richtig der Kopf flötet, sehr hoch ist.
Also können wir so weitermachen?
Ja, das sowieso, aber ich wollte ja nur mal so ein bisschen zwischenschieben, weil ich bin ja immer so ein bisschen so als Fake-Programmierer unterwegs.
Jetzt doch! Vorhin hast du mich noch geschimpft.
Du hast gesagt, ich wäre ein Nicht-Programmierer und das stimmt nicht.
Fake-Programmierer.
Okay, ein Fake-Programmierer.
Ja, weil... Ich schaue mir ja gerne so Poemiersprachen an. Mich interessiert das einfach kulturell. Also auch kulturell im Sinne von wie denken Menschen über dieses Problem nach, Lösungen mit Computern anzustreben? Dieses Denken in einer Programmiersprache formt einfach das Denken. Weil ja auch diese Programmiersprache aus einem entsprechenden Denken geformt ist. Wenn man halt so ein bisschen Überblick hat über welche Programmiersprachen es überhaupt gibt und was für Leute die auch so entwickelt haben und wie die so drauf sind und was da so für Kulturen dahinter sind, dann versteht man halt auch schnell, warum einfach hinter bestimmten Programmiersprachen auch so Leute stecken, wo man vielleicht nicht so viel mit zu tun haben will, auch wenn das nicht immer für alle gelten muss. Und dass es bei anderen Programmiersprachen eine deutlich höhere Dichte von Leuten gibt, die einfach so einen bestimmten mentalen Groove drauf haben, die einfach so eine gewisse Peilung von den Planeten und ihren Aufgaben besitzen.
Jetzt hätte ich gerne ein paar Beispiele.
Ein Beispiel ist ja so, da wurde in den 50er Jahren dieses Lisp ausgedacht. Und dann gibt es irgendwie 1000 Leute, die sagen, Lisp ist ja voll alt und hat ja viel zu viele Klammern. Und stürzen sich dann auf irgendwie ihre 80er Jahre Programmiersprache, was weiß ich, Pascal oder irgendein Kack. Und wenn du dann solche Programmiersprachen anschaust, was die konzeptionell können, bzw. was die konzeptionell sind, alles nicht können. Also was die alles falsch machen und was die alles überhaupt nicht auch nur im Ansatz können. Wie viele Schwierigkeiten du hast. So was wie Pascal oder Basic oder diesen ganzen einfachen 80er, 90er Jahre, 90er, weniger, aber vor allem 70er, 80er Jahre Sprachen. Wie wenig du da ausdrücken kannst. Wie wenig komplexe Datenstrukturen du da anlegen kannst. Wie schwierig es ist, komplexe Datenstrukturen nicht nur aufzubauen, sondern auch darüber zu ethyrieren und darüber irgendwelche Funktionen aufzurufen und die irgendwie zu transformieren oder irgendwas, was man einfach beim Programmieren braucht. Da fasst man sich halt wirklich am Kopf, wenn man sich anschaut, dass Lesb, das im Prinzip in den 50er Jahren alles schon gelöst hat. Und dass auch viele Programmiersprachen, auch so Ruby und so weiter, also so Sprachen, die so mit so einer gewissen Hektik auch geboren worden sind. Da sitzt halt so ein Japaner und sagt ich brauche jetzt so eine Programmiersprache und so und so heißt Ruby. Ist langsam. Und ist an zwei, drei Stellen cool und passte gerade in die Zeit und hatte irgendwie so den richtigen Feel. Stimmt doch. Und das, was er unbedingt damit machen wollte, ging super damit. Und da waren auch ein paar kolossal gute Ideen, wie irgendwie die Syntax geschmeidig ist und so weiter. Aber es war definitiv nicht so, dass der sich erstmal in so einem Zen-Modus fünf Jahre ins Bett gesetzt hat und darüber nachgedacht hat, wie diese Programmiersprache zu sein ist. Der hat sie im Wesentlichen ausgespuckt.
Hört ihr alle die Ruhe vor dem Shitstorm? Ich rede nicht über dich, sondern über die Leute, die das jetzt hören.
Was ich meine ist, dass du dann in den folgenden Jahren bei Ruby und so weiter, dann kommen halt so diese 2.0 und 3.0 Initiativen, wo dann so, naja, vielleicht bräuchten wir dann doch mal so Closures und eigentlich bauen alle die ganze Zeit in diese Sprachen, dann die nächsten 10, 20 Jahre Pearl und so weiter. Alle bauen Lisp ein. Also alle wollen eigentlich am Ende Lisp haben, aber es soll immer noch so aussehen, wie ihre Lieblingsprogramm ihr Sprach.
Naja, der Mats wollte Lisp und Smalltalk und Pearl im Wesentlichen in eine fluffige Kombination gießen und noch Eifel.
Jaja, aber es war halt mehr Smalltalk.
Also der Mats ist ja eher so ein Programmier-Language-Nerd, als jetzt wirklich so Wissenschaftler, sagen wir mal, und der hat sich das eher so angeguckt, die Sprache finde ich ganz geil und die Sprache finde ich ganz geil und das Konzept und das Konzept und hat das so zusammengepuzzelt, ohne jetzt die VM und so jetzt auf Edelstahl-Rostbrei zu tunen und Teflon beschichtet.
Ich übertreibe jetzt auch ein bisschen. Ich wollte ja auch was anderes hinaus. Also was man halt sehen kann ist, so eine Proamin-Sprache strahlt einfach auch so eine gewisse Aura aus und sagt einfach viel aus über die Leute, die es benutzen. Und jetzt komme ich auch wieder auf Erlang zurück. Was ich an Erlang nämlich, was ich nämlich an Erlang, als ich mich dann damit auseinandergesetzt habe, ohne jetzt viel Code produziert zu haben, ich habe da so ein bisschen rumgestochen und mir das irgendwie angeschaut, vergegenwärtig, aber ich wollte es einfach mal verstehen, wie es sein kann, dass in den 90er Jahren eine Programmiersprache aus dem Feld kommt, die sich wirklich den Luxus erlaubt, komplett anders auszusehen, als alles andere. Das ist doch das Hauptding. Wenn du sagst, hier Erlang ist geil, guck dir das mal an, und dann kommt so ein vielleicht erfahrener Programmierer mit 4,5.
Strichpunkt, Komma, Punkt, Punkt, das ist schon so zart.
Ja, nur wenn du halt mal die Syntax geschneit hast, dann merkst du halt auch sofort, wie viel Aha da drin ist.
Ja, das hat bei mir eine Weile gedauert, aber irgendwann tatsächlich kommt man in den Modus, wo man denkt, ja eigentlich ist es schon auch ganz gut.
Ja genau, das sind einfach sehr viele gute Entscheidungen. Das finde ich an diesem Erlang-Team einfach so bemerkenswert, dass sie dieses Ding neu aufgezogen haben, mit einer ganz klaren Vision für eine Softwareproblematik, die damals irgendwie noch sehr confined war auf ihren Bereich, nämlich Telefonanlagen, die aber heutzutage mega wichtig sind für alle Software, die wir im Internet haben. Schnell reagieren können, leitweit, verteilt auf mehreren Systemen, distributed über mehrere Notes und auch Prozessorkerne und so weiter. Alle anderen Programmiersprachen hauen sich da einen irgendwie, der Objective-C musste über Jahre gebürstet werden, bis dann irgendwie mal ein Konstrukt da war, dass man auch mal mit mehr als einer CPU gleichzeitig Code ausführen kann. Und Grand Central und großer Bahnhof und Pipa-Pro. Und bei Erlang war das halt einfach mal drin.
Und vor allen Dingen haben die auch bei Erlang tatsächlich, weil halt die Hardware von den Telefonanlagen damals auch war ja auch limitiert, sagen wir mal, von der Kapazität und Power und so. Die haben halt auch bestimmte Constraints in ihrer Sprache, dass bestimmte Konstrukte eben auch gewisse Anforderungen an Soft-Real-Time oder Real-Time halt erfüllen müssen. Zum Beispiel diese Guards. Also du kannst ja, wenn du so Pattern matchst, kannst du danach nochmal so eine Guard-Express machen. Die sind limitiert auf Typenabfragen und da vielleicht Länge noch von irgendwelchen Konstrukten, aber die sind zum Beispiel garantiert, dass sie immer in Konstanzzeit laufen. Egal welche Datenstruktur da rein kippst in diesen Guard. Und da sind halt eben so ein paar Konstrukte drin, die siehst du halt auch bei vielen Sprachen einfach nicht und die sind eben auch aus diesen frühen so Telefonanlagen und das Ding nageln wir jetzt an die Palme und wollen nach Möglichkeit auch nach 23 Jahren, dass das Ding immer noch irgendwie sich so selber heilen kann oder performt in bestimmten Situationen. Und das ist halt in der Sprache schon ziemlich speziell. Und gerade so dieses Pattern-Matching, jetzt wo es eben diese Hashmaps auch gibt, du gehst halt auch wirklich ganz anders noch mit diesen Datenstrukturen dann um.
Genau, jetzt weiß ich auch wieder, warum ich das überhaupt aufgebracht habe. Das mit den Hashmaps ist natürlich jetzt insofern interessant, als das jetzt nämlich auch die Erlang-Welt auf einmal eine andere Notwendigkeit gesehen hat, sich wiederum an die anderen anzupassen. Also wo sie konzeptionell sehr viel richtig gemacht haben und sich eine Syntax dafür ausgedacht hat, die einfach passt, haben sie jetzt auf einmal auch mit einer Welt zu tun, nämlich Internet und Text und dieser ganze Kram, wo du einfach vollkommen verzweifelst mit dem alten Erlang, wie es noch vor ein paar Versionen war und jetzt könnte das noch interessanter sein, sich genau das anzuschauen.
Die Coco Objective-C-Sache von Hashmaps, die gibt es halt auch seit Day 1. Also da war es halt schon immer drin als Datencontainer.
Bei Erlang gibt es halt Diktionaries und es gibt Binary, also GB-Trees nennt sich das im Prinzip auch, ein Diktionary basierend auf dem Binary Tree. Das gab es schon nur... Das war halt nicht das, was man heutzutage so unter so einem Hash oder assoziativen Array oder was auch immer versteht. Und jetzt haben sie halt auch ganz viel an der Syntax-Schraube tatsächlich gedreht und haben sich eben auch, ich glaube auch schon, weil so jetzt so ein, zwei Ruby-Checker da so mit am Board sind und einfach auch ein bisschen gezeigt haben, wie man so mal das mit Elixier halt auch lösen kann. Und die sich mit dem auch viel unterhalten haben. Deswegen haben die glaube ich jetzt auch so die Hash-Maps tatsächlich benutzt halt das gleiche Zeichen für Key-Value-Assoziation wie Ruby tatsächlich auch. Aber macht da, also sie haben verschiedene Operatoren, da kannst du nämlich auch Conditional Updates im Hash und so machen, wenn der Value schon gesetzt ist, dann nicht überschreiben und so weiter und so fort und naja, auf jeden Fall, ich kann euch auch nach wie vor nur, wenn ihr mal wirklich so Backends entwickelt für was auch immer, also wirklich, das kann der kleinste Scheiß sein oder das größte System. Erlang ist geil und Funktional-Programmieren ist halt auch, ich hatte jetzt ja gerade davor wieder so ein Team, wo ich objektorientiert programmiert hab mit Ruby, jetzt wieder Funktional und dann sitzt man halt erstmal auch wieder da und denkt sich so, so, so, jetzt hier gehe ich mal da durch die Datenstruktur durch und hier mal ein Wert geändert und da mal ein Wert geändert und dann donnert man erstmal mit der Nase wieder an die Glasscheibe und merkt so ah, stop, Funktional, keine Variable, zweimal zuweisen, keine Seiteneffekte, also nicht das, so Seiteneffekte, das konnte ich mir auch irgendwie lange Zeit hier immer nicht so vorstellen, weil Ruby gibt zum Beispiel auf dem Hasch eine Methode Delete und was die macht ist, du gibst ihr einen Key und einen Hasch Du hast hier einen Hasch und du kriegst raus den Value, der Deleted wurde mit dem Key. Und aber als Seiteneffekt wird der Hasch auch gekürzt um dieses Element. Es sind halt zwei Sachen in einer Aktion sozusagen. Ja, nee, der entfernt den Key und gibt dir aber den Value, den er gerade entfernt hat, als Resultat raus. Aber er hat zwei Objekte quasi geändert. Den Hasch, wo er das Element rausgenommen hat. Also zwei Effekte und gibt dir aber als Resultat den Value und nicht den veränderten Hasch. Das heißt...
Der Comics sozusagen.
Ja, aber er ändert den Effect. Du sagst nicht explizit, ändere mir den Hasch oder gib mir den Value, wie der Hasch aussehen würde ohne den Value, sondern du machst halt zwei Sachen. Und das geht halt ja so...
Und er ändert das in Place. Das ist das, was du sagst. Ja, das ist eigentlich eine Sache von Switft, die mir sehr gut gefällt, dass sie das mit dem Single Assignment dann auch durchziehen. Also wenn du eine Variable lett machst, dann ist die Single Assignment fertig. Und was ganz gut ist an einem Switft 0-Compiler, ist, wenn der eine Variable findet, die nur einmal Assigned wird, dann macht er eine Compiler Warning nach der Art, die wird nur einmal Assigned, macht da mal ein Let draus. Was sehr schön ist, weil man fängt wirklich an, fast nur noch Letts zu verwenden.
Aber macht der normale C-Compiler das nicht auch? Also man kann da jetzt auch bei C überall Konst hinschreiben und so, aber das macht optimiert der Compiler doch auch weg.
Ja, Konst ist aber nochmal ein bisschen was anderes als Single Assignment.
Vor allen Dingen bei dem Erlang ist es ja auch immer schon so gewesen und dann, was da zuviel ist, du könntest halt jetzt anfangen, das eine Datenschrott tun, du willst 23 Operationen machen, dann machst du halt, sagen wir mal, Data 0, Data 1, Data 2 bis Data 23. Und das ist natürlich, wenn du das hinschreibst, dann weißt du schon, falscher Weg, weil dann baut man sich halt so eine schöne Fold oder wie auch immer, dass er dann in der nähwürdigen Sprache heißt. Eine Funktion, die halt so das schön funktional transformiert und dann hat man automatisch gleich so eine transaktionale Verhaltensweise, weil wenn eine Transformation in diesem Fold failt und eine Exception wirft, kannst du halt sofort wieder zu dem Ursprungs-State zurückfallen und sagen, ok, wenn es jetzt hier irgendwie was schief geht, dann gib einfach den unveränderten State sozusagen zurück. Also entweder alle Transaktionen gehen durch oder gar nicht. Und da kann man halt sehr viel, ja so, wenn man dann später wieder objektorientiert programmiert, dann fühlt, also ich hab mich dann echt schmutzig gefühlt, wenn dann so Sachen passieren und dachte mir so, ah, dieses objektorientierte, das ist aber auch wirklich... Ich meine, ich muss auch sagen, das hängt auch mit diesem Actormodel zusammen, weil dadurch hast du eben auch nochmal so eine ganz andere Isolation zwischen den einzelnen funktionalen Komponenten. Und ich muss auch sagen, nachdem ich das jetzt bestimmt schon drei Jahre lang da ja auch bei Bugha mache, dieses Actormodel ist einfach das Geilste für so...
Also du meinst dieses Konzept, was das OTP-Framework aufmacht, dass man Prozesse hat, die sich automatisch starten etc.?
Nee, nee, nee. Also ich meine bei objektorientiert, da sind ja die Prinzipien immer so, also Inheritance haben wir, man hat so Polymorphism, dann gibt es noch irgendwie das nächste Wichtige, das ist auf jeden Fall Encapsulation und Message Passing, ist ja eigentlich auch noch so eins. Und Encapsulation sagt ja, das ist ja würde ich sagen, die Essenz vom UOP, dass der State im Objekt encapsuliert wird und die Funktionalität, um den State zu transformieren. Und wenn du es machst mit Message Passing, schickst du halt dem Objekt so Nachrichten, was jetzt da zu tun ist. So, das gleiche ist letztendlich ja beim Actor-Model auch. Der Actor encapsulated auch den State und er encapsulated auch die Funktionalität, um den zu transformieren. Und du schickst auch Messages hin, was du jetzt machen willst. Und es gibt auch noch Polymorphism, weil du kannst ja auch zwei unterschiedliche Actor auf die gleiche Nachricht im Prinzip reagieren lassen und dann verhalten die sich genauso, obwohl sie unterschiedlich sind. Aber der fundamentale Unterschied ist halt, dass das Objekt lebt halt im Globalspeicher. Also wenn zum Beispiel du ein Auto-Objekt hast und dann will ein Thread Bremse und ein Thread Gas geben, gibt es halt Race Condition Bumm. Du musst da halt mit Mutex und Loggen und sonst was. Und was dir das Actor-Model halt for free gibt, ist diese Serialisierung des Zugriffs sozusagen. Da gibt es halt einfach keine Race Condition. Zu einer Zeit gibt es nur einen, der diesen Actor spielen darf. Und dann bremst du zuerst und dann darfst du Gas geben und das kriegst du halt for free. Und das ist so eine große, das nimmt mir schon so viel weg, einfach von diesem ganzen Schmerz mit Threads und Logs.
Naja, aber ich muss sagen, Threads und Logs benutzt man da, so in der Praxis auch in Coco nicht mehr so.
Ja, aber es gibt es halt noch in vielen anderen Ecken natürlich trotzdem.
Übrigens, wer mal so ein bisschen den Vortrag darüber hören will, was eigentlich so alles an der objektorientierten Programmierung schiefgelaufen ist. Also ich habe den Vortrag leider noch nicht ganz gesehen, aber die erste Hälfte war schon mal geil. Das ist dieser hier, der heißt von der WWDC, Protocol Oriented Programming in Swift. Da zählt er mal so ganz schön auf, wie macht man das eigentlich in der objektorientierten Programmierung und was sind da eigentlich so die Probleme mit, die wir alle so kennen. Ist so schön, wie er immer das beschreibt. Und dann, das kennen wir doch alle, oder? Und alle im Publikum so, Verhaltenes, Lachen.
Ja, ist der Vortrag, genau.
Der heißt Protocol Oriented Programming in Swift. Wo er da so ein Case aufmacht, dass das mit der Inheritance vielleicht doch nur so ein mittleres, so eine mittlere Idee war.
Ja, alle kommen jetzt ab von Inheritance und Objektorientierung. Das ist halt einfach durch.
Das neueste, was ich gehört habe, war der Begriff VO. Also der Funktionalobjekt orientiert. Das scheint so das neue Passwort zu sein. geschrieben wie falsches O, wie französisch falsch.
Ich meine, die Sprachen, mit denen man üblicherweise so richtig was gewuppt kriegt, sind ja eh die Sprachen, die mehrere Paradigmen miteinander verheiraten. Also Heskel, was jetzt vielleicht am ersten an der Funktionalen rein leere ist, damit ist es halt sehr schwer, auch mit der Realität zu interagieren.
Du hast das mit den Monaden richtig verstanden? Was keiner hat, ja.
Also auch Lisp ist ja keine reine funktionale Sprache. Es hat ja auch so ein Multiple Paradigm, oder wie man das auch eigentlich nennt, Multi-Paradigm-Language.
Das Original, Swift, Lisp.
Was heißt das Original, Lisp? Aber das, was es halt so mit diesem ganzen, wie heißt es, dieses Object-System und...
Das Common Lisp Object System, ja. Das hat sozusagen noch mal ein Objektsystem zu Lisp obendrauf gepackt, aber Lisp selber ist die Essenz von funktionaler Poemiersprachung. Da hast du gar nichts anderes in Lisp.
Naja, aber du hast Seiteneffekte in dem Fall. Wie? Nein. In Lisp? Hast du keine Seiteneffekte?
Wie?
Also, kann man da nicht auf dem Bild schon mal was ausgeben oder mal von einer Socket was lesen oder? Also ich meine, die reine Funktionallehre wäre ja wirklich, du läufst in deiner Schrödinger Katzebox und nur wenn du reinguckst, dann ist es auch schon nicht mehr funktional.
Du kopierst immer die ganze Bitmap, um eine Pixel zu ändern.
Ja, genau. Ich sag ja auch, Erlang ist halt auch eine von diesen Sprachen, die halt, ja, also wir sind zwar schon überwiegend funktional, aber wir haben schon so ein paar Sachen, um, ne? Und Ruby ist halt auch eigentlich eine der reinsten objektorientierten Sprachen, weil wirklich alles ein Objekt und alles eine Methode ist. Selbst der Plus-Operator ist eine Methode und kann überladen werden. Aber letztendlich haben sie halt auch viele funktionale Konzepte mit drin. Und es gibt eigentlich selten Sprachen, die jetzt immer so dir absolut reine Lehre vertreten. Aber, ja, also hier, was war denn das letztens noch? Aber diese ganzen Inheritance-Sachen zum Beispiel, das war ja auch bei Ruby so eine Sache, da gibt es ja auch diese Mix-Ins. Und da wurde auch schon viel drüber gesprochen, dass Inheritance eigentlich in den meisten Fällen blöd ist. Und dann, wenn du dir so ein Java-Projekt heutzutage mal anguckst, oder ein Android-Projekt, wo dann wirklich ohne Scheiß, du hast 23 Klassen für den kleinsten, furzigen Task. Und dann ist das wirklich so der Singleton-Factory, wie auch immer, abstract, hast du nicht gesehen, Integer. Und dann guckst du da rein, und was es tut, ist irgendwie ein Integer einfach nochmal in irgendwas anderes zu rappen. Und du gehst aber 23 Klassentiefen drunter und kannst auch nur die Art benutzen, wenn du die extendest dann noch, und dann wirst du doch echt bräsig in der Birne. Naja, also checkt mal, wer es noch nicht gemacht hat, Elixir ist für die fluffige Erlang-Version. Wenn ihr es hart wollt, dann Learn You Some Erlang for Great Good ist auf jeden Fall. Das ist das E-Book quasi, kann man auch kaufen, aber das kann man kostenlos vollständig lesen.
Ist das auch schon aktuell für?
Es gibt, er hat unten so ein Amendment gemacht.
Und selbst, wenn ihr es nicht lest, klickt euch durch und guckt euch die Bilder an.
Ja, der hat auch super geile...
Der Typ, der zeichnet die alle selber und es ist irgendwie, die sind immer wieder großartig.
Er hat unten auch, was eben noch, letztes Wort, jetzt noch zu Erlang18, was noch dazugekommen ist, sie haben die Time-Arpy komplett irgendwie overhauled. Sie kommen jetzt auch mit Leapsacken super gut klar. Und die Zeichnung, guckt ihr mal.
Just in time.
Geh mal zurück in den Index und klickt mal, weil der hat da super geile Illustration gemacht, wie es vorher war und wie es jetzt ist mit der Zeit, ganz unten, genau. Postscript, time goes on. Du warst ganz unten, da warst du schon. Ganz ganz unten. Da, klick einfach mal auf das erste. Ja, das ist ja alles in einem Kapitel. So, und jetzt kommen wir runter ein bisschen. Und dann so, da wird jetzt für die Hörer abgebildet, dass in Erlang halt zwischen der Zeit, die das Betriebssystem einem gibt und der realen Zeit halt schon merkwürdige Unterschiede geben kann. Und dann gab es in Erlang noch ein zweites Konzept von Zeit, das war sozusagen von der Virtual Machine, die aber auch, sagen wir mal, nicht 100% Linear erfolgt. Und dann hat er halt hier so die absurdesten Grafen, wie so die Zeiten dann auseinanderdriften können. Und halt auch echt lustige Beschreibungen dazu. Und dann hat er aber auch so coole Diagramme, um seine Punkte irgendwie zu erklären. Lohnt sich. Also der Typ ist wirklich cool.
Das hat sich aber auch sehr verändert, hier diese Webseite, wenn ich das mal... Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so bunt in Erinnerung.
Nö, die war schon immer bunt. Ja, gleich schon auf der... Ja, du musst auf Home klicken. Das muss ich eben nochmal sagen, dass er den hätte mal.
Wir verlinken das.
Wir verlinken das. Ist cool, ja.
Dann news am Erlang.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr lustig.
Gut, wollen wir das Thema dann mal abrunden? Also, wer jetzt nichts verstanden hat, nicht so schlimm. Wer immer noch zuhört, trotzdem Suppi. Und wer von euch auf, ich wollte schon immer mal das mit dem Programmieren mal so richtig verstehen, ich sage Erlang gehört ins Paket, in diese kleine Box.
Wenn man sich noch nicht mit was anderem versaut hat, kann man damit auf jeden Fall anfangen.
Na das Geile war jetzt zum Beispiel dieser Rich Hackey, der Closure gemacht hat. Die Rich Hackey Talks, die sind ja auch richtig großartig. Er meint auch in einem solchen Talks, wo es um State und Parallelisierung geht, er erkläre euch jetzt noch mal die Grundlagen.
Aber wenn ihr Erlang-Programmierer seid, dann könnt ihr jetzt schon mal, Skip, Skip machen. Dann habt ihr es schon verstanden. Obwohl er selber eine Sprache quasi so pitched. Er hat auch nur Erlang gesagt.
Bei den Programmiersprachentwicklern, die es verstanden haben, haben die dann auch den entsprechenden Respekt voreinander. Aber Clojure hätte jetzt eigentlich auch noch mal so ein Segment verdient, aber das kann ich leider hier nicht bedienen. Müssen wir uns mal einen Clojure-Experten reinholen. Aber die Talks von Rich Hickey, die sind wirklich fantastisch. Der Typ ist wirklich ein Nerd-Entertainment-Deluxe.
Und der kann auch supergut erklären.
Genau, selbst wenn man mit Clojure nichts machen will, wie er überhaupt die Probleme von Programmieren an sich und Datenbanken und alles Mögliche...
Da gibt es so einen Talk über State und Entities und so weiter, wo eben auch so dieses, was ich gerade meinte, mit objektorientiert ist, so und mit Mecto-Model ist so. Und da erzählt er halt noch so zwei andere Varianten und erklärt es aber auch so cool, dass man, weil so über diesen State in so einem Parallelen- oder Konkurrenzsystem hat man halt auch noch nicht so richtig nahe gedacht. Und er ist dann halt irgendwie, der macht einem so richtig mal kurz Augen auf. Macht nochmal die linke Linse rauf.
Erlang lernen ist auf jeden Fall eye-opening. Also das...
Bei InfoQ, da gab es glaube ich ein paar von den Richhacky-Talks.
Ja, hier gibt es All of Richhacky, genau, das versuche ich mal. Das ist ein ganz großes Kino.
Den können wir mal auf den Kongress oder so einladen.
Den sollten wir eigentlich wirklich mal einladen. Ach ja, hier, irgendwie. Allein schon seine Haarpracht. Functional Database, das ist auch so großartig, wo er wirklich, also wirklich alles, was irgendwie vorne ein S und hinten ein L hat, einfach so komplett in die Tonne tritt. Und er hat so recht. Da willst du nie wieder SQL anfassen nach dem Talk.
Ja, der ist, also das wirklich, also den hätte ich zum Beispiel tatsächlich gerne auch mal auf dem Kongress, auch wenn das vielleicht so themenmäßig so Programmiersprachen oder sowas.
Aber der könnte so einen super Meta-Talk halten.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall eins, wo so die ordentlich gekifften Hacker dann da sitzen und so. Er kann auch so entspannt über die reine Leere sprechen einfach.
Fantastisch. Gut, jetzt Schluss mit Programmieren.
Oder?
Jetzt haben wir es.
Dennis guckt nur.
Dennis, hast du noch ein Thema am Start?
Zusätzlich zu denen, die da schon stehen?
Nein.
Oder ist da noch irgendwas, was dich...
Na, ich kann jetzt bei Apple Music noch ein bisschen mitreden.
Ach so, dann machen wir das doch einfach.
Bumshakalaka, hier kommen die mit Schnacker. Und gestern, als es das Thema auch schon gab, gab es das auch noch nicht, weil iTunes 12.2.2 oder 12.2. nicht released wurde mit Apple Music. Da gab es das nur gestern Abend auf dem iPhone oder dem iOS-Gerät.
Also ich habe das heute Morgen mal angemacht und...
Ja, genau. Ich wollte mal dazu sagen, gestern Abend um 17 Uhr kam iOS 8.4. Das hat überhaupt erst mal die Möglichkeit, dass man dieses Apple Music hören kann. Und der passende Radiosender dazu, dieser Beats One, der wurde erst um 18 Uhr gegen deren Live-Programm da los. Vorher lief die ganze Stunde lang, weil ich war schon um halb sechs fertig, lief die ganze halbe Stunde lang, glaube ich, Brian Eno mit Music for Airports oder so.
Na, ich habe mir das heute mal angehört und war underwhelmed.
Ja, das ist wirklich das, das...
Ja, aber dafür, wie hoch sie es aufgehängt haben, ist es doch relativ tief gefallen. In meinen Augen. Aber gut. Aber das kann ich nicht einfach so erwarten.
Das ist halt so ein... Das heißt Hipster, was heißt Hipster. Also klar, wollen die auch ein bisschen hip sein da bei Apple und spielen halt Zeug, was irgendwie gerade angesagt ist, mischen dann aber auch alle Genres irgendwie quer durcheinander. Ich weiß nicht, ob der, der AC DC hört, auch dann irgendwie Eminem hört, oder weiß nicht, was die da alles so gespielt haben. Also es war ein bisschen sehr bunte Tüte. Das passt nicht so richtig.
Aber ich fand London noch mehr bunte Tüte als eigentlich New York. Naja, es gibt ja irgendwie diese drei quasi Studios.
Wo war ich?
Blah, DJ, Blah, Blah, Blah aus London. Also London hört man auch an der Sprache so ein bisschen.
Ja, okay, der Lounge war mit diesem Zane Low oder wie er heißt. Und der war ja aus Los Angeles. Und da war, ja ich fand...
Und ihr habt jetzt das Radio am meisten gefolgt?
Ich hab das heute angehört.
Da können wir gleich darüber diskutieren, warum, also ich zum Beispiel, warum mich dieses Music-Angebot für 10 Dollar oder Euro im Monat nicht interessiert. Deswegen ist das Radio das einzige, was mich überhaupt interessieren würde. Aber von der Musik ist es halt nicht so mein Ding, was sie erst so hatten. Und dann hatte ich aber nachts um 3 nochmal reingehört. Und da war ganz witzig, da die haben irgendwie so ein St. Vincent oder St. Vincent ist glaube ich auch so eine Band, aber die hat da auch so ein bisschen Musik gemacht. Und sie hat so ein Ding, dass man ihr schreiben kann und sie macht dann so eine Art Wunschliste und das war halt für so ein kleines Mädchen. Da habe ich schon mit Tim mich unterhalten und er meinte, er hat das heute gehört und ich habe das letzte Nacht um 3 gehört. Das heißt, die wiederholen das Zeug auch. Also es ist nicht 24 Stunden immer was Neues, sondern es werden auch Sachen wiederholt, wie es im Radio halt so ist. Und da war die Musik dann schon eher so mein Geschmack. Wir haben auch mehr so alten Scheiß gespielt, mit so ein bisschen neueren mal gemixt. Aber das andere ist mir noch zu kreuz und quer durcheinander und viel davon ist nicht meins und dann kann ich das nicht so. Und sie quatschen rein ohne Ende, das geht auch gar nicht.
Oder singen mit.
Das würde ich noch okay finden, aber so reinquatschen würde ich eigentlich fast auch noch okay finden. Aber wenn sie auch immer wieder ihre Werbung, ihre Beats waren. Ich meine, ich hör's doch schon, ihr müsst mich nicht überzeugen. Ich weiß, dass es Beats waren, ich hab's ja an, Jungs. Also, ganz blöde sind die Hörer nicht.
Für mich ist dieses Radio von vornherein schon das Uninteressante, dass es überhaupt an dem ganzen Ding gewesen ist. Ich hab überhaupt keinen einzigen Funken-Motivation, da überhaupt auf Listen zu klicken.
Ich wollte es mir mal anhören. Ich wollte es mir mal anhören. Ich hab heute Vormittag gehört, als London gerade dran war. Und London war insofern ganz interessant, weil die wirklich eine komplette Kraut- und Rübenmischung gespielt haben. Also erst ein bisschen elektronisch, dann irgendwie Haus. Dann haben sie irgendwie Britpop gespielt. Dann haben sie Reggae gespielt. Dann haben sie David Bowie mit Rapper gespielt. Und Rod Stewart mit Rapper dabei und so weiter. Und ich dachte mir so, ey, was wird das hier? Dann kam New York und dann Hip-Hop. Bisschen anderer Hip-Hop, nochmal Hip-Hop. Erst Hip-Hop aus Brooklyn, dann Hip-Hop aus der Bronx, dann Hip-Hop aus, weiß ich nicht, dann Hip-Hop von dem. Und das angesagte Hip-Hop von so und so. Und dann meinte er, ja, aber wir spielen ja nicht nur Hip-Hop. Und dann hat er irgendwie Soul gespielt. Und dann wieder Hip-Hop. Und dann nochmal Hip-Hop. Und dann nochmal Hip-Hop. Und dann hab ich ausgemacht. Ich dachte mir so, ey Leute.
Das ist halt USA und da ist das halt so. Hip-Hop ist die Definition von Pop-Post.
Was sie sagen, sie machen Musik für die ganze Welt. So, hm, dann sollen sie halt 2, 3 Sender machen.
Aber doch nicht, wenn die Amerikaner zuhören. Nur wenn die Europäer zuhören. Ich finde das an sich ganz interessant. Im Prinzip müssten sie eigentlich so für jeden Kontinental-Vertikalbereich immer so einen 3-Stunden-Block machen. Oder 5, 6 Stunden.
Am geilsten war auch London. Die Frau so, nach dem nächsten Song müsst ihr eure ID bereithalten. Die braucht ihr dann noch. Ich so, hm, naja, dann hat sie irgendwas gespielt. So, jetzt braucht ihr eure ID. Weil jetzt gehen wir in den Club. Und dann hat sie halt da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, so Haus gespielt.
Das glaube ich, habe ich auch gehört. Und dann hat sie gesagt, jetzt stellt euch vor, ihr geht jetzt in einen Club, bla bla. Wenn ihr noch nie in einem Club wart, aha. Also, wer hat wirklich beschrieben, wie man in eine Disco geht?
Der Witz war auch so.
Mir tut es schon wie beim Zuhören. Irgendwie von euren Erzählungen.
Manche Sachen, das mit dem Girl fand ich ganz cool. Das ist mehr so in meiner Ecke gewesen. Das ist wahrscheinlich dieser zu moderne Hipster-Kram. Das ist ja auch Geschmackssache.
Und dann kam da manchmal was, wo ich dachte, ach, das würdest du vielleicht nochmal nachhören, ob es dir nicht wirklich gefällt. Und dann habe ich da rumgeklickt. Gibt es irgendwo einen Merken?
Oder gibt es einen Favorit? Bei The Verge gibt es eine Spotify-Playlist, die alle Songs aus den Beats 1 macht, seit Eröffnung. Da kannst du auch gucken, wie es losging.
Die Leute haben Sachen zu tun.
Das kann man ja automatisieren, wahrscheinlich. Das ist einfach sein, wie heißt das? Scroll mal durch, wo die gerade sind. Also heute Nacht um 3 waren sie so bei 80 Songs. Hier, die Liste da oben, da kannst du scrollen.
Hier kann man scrollen, ach so.
Alles klar, sind wir jetzt bei 172.
Okay, das heißt, er hat da irgendwie seinen Chassam vor dem Stream und fertig.
Genau.
Ja, kann man das ja auch schön automatisieren. Irgendwas wollte ich gerade noch sagen. Ah ja, genau. Beats waren... Also ich mach mir da nicht viel Illusionen. Das ist halt ein Radiosender, der macht Musik für die Welt. Also da wird man jetzt keine intellektuellen Hochleistungen erwarten. Dafür fand ich es jetzt nicht so unangenehm, wie ich es erwartet hatte.
Ja, beim ersten Mal hat es die Werbung rein.
Für sich selbst, sonst nicht.
Nein, für Candy Crush war die Werbung drin.
Ja, also Tronsat bei Tralala...
Das habe ich ja nicht gehört.
Noch ein Gros...
Das ist wirklich uncool. Das könnten sie sich auch komplett schenken. Was ich aber jetzt noch interessant finde...
Candy Crush war die Konkurrenz von euch, ne?
Eigentlich müssen wir auch nochmal über Jelly-Splash reden. Interessant wird ja... Sie erwähnen ja dann auch zwischendurch immer dieses Connect-Feature. Also sozusagen im Livestream kommt ja sowas, ja, ihr könnt jetzt irgendwie auf den Connect-Button und lalala. Da tauchen dann quasi die Künstler auf. Also sie haben ja so ein Follower-Modell.
Ja, toll. Ich habe... Ich versuche das erstmal...
Ich versuche das doch zu erklären.
Maßregelung.
Ich habe da überhaupt gar keine Meinung zu. Ich erkläre nur, wie es ist. Wir wussten ja alle nicht, was für eine Art Ping da jetzt wieder rauskommt. Aber es ist ja schon klar, dass hier irgendein Follower-Modell auch implementiert wird und so ist es auch. Das heißt, was sie machen ist, innerhalb ihrer App haben sie ein Outlet für Artists, wo dann irgendein Video auftaucht oder irgendein Quatsch, und das kannst du dann irgendwie kommentieren. Das ist vom User-Interface her schon wieder ein bisschen wie Ping, weil es halt irgendwie in der App ist. Tatsächlich ist es so, im Default, wenn du da mal reingehst in dieses Connect und sagst, konfigurier das mal, dann siehst du, dass da ein Setting an ist, Auto-Follow-All-Artists. Also alle, die du hörst, denen folgst du auch automatisch. Und ich dachte schon so, oh Gott, das gibt einen Shitstorm. Nur das Schöne ist, du kannst das ausschalten und wenn du es ausschaltest, dieses Auto-Follow, dann gehen auch alle weg. Also es ist nicht so, dass du dann mit so einem Satz von 300 Follower-Ships rumläufst, bis du es endlich mal ausgeschaltet bekommen hast, sondern...
Ja, was bedeutet dann Follow?
Follow heißt in dem Moment, dass dieses komische Connect-Tab, den du da auswählen kannst, dir quasi alle Artists, die du eben folgst, den Output, den sie da posten, zeigen. Ich weiß auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Okay, also brauch kein Schwein.
Wir sind auch überhaupt nicht in die Gruppe.
Ich hatte in meiner Musik-Library Nine Inch Nails drin und ich mach dieses Connect auf und es ist irgendwie gefühlt fünf Bildschirmseiten Nine Inch Nails-Kram. Alles, was mich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Achso, ich hab irgendwas Falsches erzählt. Ich hab gesagt, alles, was du auf Beats gehört hast, das stimmt nicht. Alles, was du auf Beats mit einem Herzchen oder so angeklickt hast.
Nein, schon vorher.
Und das, was du in deiner Library hast.
Ja, und ich glaube vor allen Dingen, das, was du über iTunes gekauft hast.
Also alles, was du in deiner Library hast.
Nein, alles, was du über iTunes gekauft hast.
Und nicht das, was du in deiner Library hast?
Nein, das, was du über iTunes gekauft hast. Also das ist so... Naja, ich hab jetzt dieses For You mal angemacht und hab da irgendwann mal auf Mobi... Das Lustigste, du kriegst ja diese Kreise von Künstlern. Und dann guck ich dahin, ne, zeig mir mehr. Na gut, den vielleicht noch. Zeig mir mehr, ne, zeig mir mehr, ne, zeig mir mehr. Ah, gut, den vielleicht noch. Das ist so... Also vielleicht wird das irgendwann besser, aber bis jetzt ist das eher noch so...
Das ist halt wahrscheinlich für aktuelle Musik und du hörst wahrscheinlich auch viel altes Zeug oder nicht so angesagtes.
Nicht so superaktuell, naja.
Nicht so Mainstream, ist ja am Ende schon alles Mainstream.
Aber das... ja, okay, also ich meine, ihr sprecht ja immer noch von diesem Radio und Zeug, ne?
Nee, da können wir schon von weggehen, aber ich kann dir sagen, warum ich... Also ich... Warum soll ich 10 Euro im Monat für Musikzahlen gemietet und das, sagen wir mal, die nächsten 10 Jahre lang, da sind irgendwie 1000 Euro weg oder 1200. Und dann entschließe ich mich jetzt, Apple ist doch blöd, ich will doch einen Android oder was auch immer, dann gekommen ist an den OS oder wie auch immer, ja? Und dann ist es weg und ich hab die auch nicht. Als ich früher jung war, hab ich irgendwie 200 CDs mir gebraucht, ich hab für ne Menge Musik schon bezahlt und jetzt muss ich nochmal bezahlen dafür, dass die mir das rüberstreamen.
Also ich würde mal sagen, es gibt auch bestimmt ne ganze Menge Musik, vielleicht, die...
Du nicht bezahlt hast.
Du vielleicht auch nicht.
Kann schon sein.
So, jetzt folgendes. Die Sachen, die du in deiner Library ja schon hast oder die auf irgendeinem Wege bekommst, weil du dir auf Amazon Marketplace für einen Euro eine CD gekauft hast und die gerippt hast und in dein Library getan hast, was ich tatsächlich sogar relativ oft mache, weil manchmal gibts halt einfach so die Scheiße halt nicht in diesen 30 Millionen Songs-Katalogs und dann kann man auf Amazon Marketplace halt günstig einfach die CD-Qualität schnappen. Das wird ja dann auch über die iCloud auf alle die weißen.
Ich weiß, das wird mit eingebunden.
Und für mich zum Beispiel, und das ist halt egal, wo du deine Musik her hast, egal was du jetzt gerade auf deinem Gerät hast, das dann auf allen Geräten zu haben.
Das ist das iTunes-Match-Feature von früher, das gab es ja auch schon.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt halt ein bisschen geiler und auch, also ich finde das okay und tatsächlich habe ich schon oft so diesen Moment gehabt, dass ich will jetzt mal neue Musik auschecken, dann gucke ich mal so, ob ich die in irgendwelchen Privat-Kopier-Archiven vielleicht finde von Freunden und Freundesfreunden und dann ist es halt oftmals auch, nee, dann kann ich auf Spotify gehen und mir alle drei Sekunden eine IKEA-Werbung anhören oder so oder ja, keine Ahnung, Amazon Marketplace und jetzt tatsächlich habe ich heute direkt mal gleich so ein paar Artists, die ich schon auf dieser Liste hatte, die ich eigentlich mal ein bisschen mehr hören wollte, alte Sachen und so, habe ich direkt mal heute geguckt bei Apple Music, gab es auch und habe dann einfach, dann klickst du halt einfach, dann kommt was und das finde ich an sich jetzt erstmal nicht doof.
Also ich habe mir dieses For You abgeholt, was ja die ersten drei Monate kostenlos ist, habe ich mir jetzt erstmal geklickt.
Was automatisch verlängert wird.
Aber dieses For You, das ist ja nochmal wieder eine eigene Komponente. Was du jetzt ja machen kannst sozusagen, du kannst jetzt hier oben, wenn du was suchst, zum Beispiel sagen wir mal Led Zeppelin, oben rechts in dieser Dings, dann sagt er, entweder in meiner Bibliothek oder Apple Music. Und wenn du jetzt Apple Music sagst und du kriegst das Led Zeppelin-Album und du klickst da auf, hier, was hier, das ist geil, das erste einfach, direkt auf Play, dann spielt das jetzt halt gestreamt ab, also das ist eigentlich das...
Ja, aber nur dann, wenn du das Abo hast.
Genau, aber dieses For You, das ist ein extra Feature wiederum von diesem ganzen...
Ja, okay, von dem Abo.
Wo du sagst, so das sind meine Interessen und du klickst hier in den Herzen, da in den Herzen, da in der Mandel...
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum ich hier nicht irgendwie wenigstens die Store-Preview kriege, wenn ich nicht das Abo abgeschlossen habe. Das ist irgendwie so...
Na, wenn du im iTunes-Store, den gibt's ja weiterhin. Da kannst du ja auch...
Ja, aber warum sind das zwei getrennte Seiten?
Das wird wahrscheinlich noch vereinheitlicht werden, aber... Das, was mich bisher eigentlich so ein bisschen irritiert hatte, war, dass ich dachte, okay, ich hab ja in iTunes meine ganze Library so als Blick, ne? Und jetzt dachte ich, okay, jetzt mach ich mein iPhone-Music auf und dann sehe ich einfach meine gesamte Library und nur das, was sie nicht im Store haben, wird sozusagen über die iCloud gesüngt. Und alles, was die haben, das wird dann halt, weiß nicht, mit so einem kleinen gestrichelten Cloud-Icon vielleicht angezeigt, aber ich kann es auch genauso browsen und es fühlt sich so an, als wäre meine Library genauso auch da. Und dieses Feature, das fehlt halt leider noch. Du musst halt immer suchen nach den Art, das du streamen willst. Ist nicht so, dass du den gleichen View hast wie auf deinem Rechner zum Beispiel und dann wird On-Demand halt gestreamt und du kannst auch noch mehr suchen.
Und wird auch lokal gar nicht mehr cash. Das heißt, ich hab immer voll die Daten, die da flatter, wenn ich Musik höre.
Was mit dem Cash noch nicht geguckt, aber ich hab heute mal, weil ja dann auch die ganzen Artikel kamen, so von wegen, ja, wie sind denn jetzt die Services-Unterschiede zwischen Spotify und Apple Music und Google Music und Amazon und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Und dann ist ja ein Punkt immer die Bitrate. Und Spotify macht, glaube ich, also wenn du bezahlst, kriegst du 320 Kilobit, aber ich glaube, es ist halt mp3. Und dann wurde vermutet, Apple hat es ja nicht gesagt, dass es 256 Kilobit ARC ist, wie im Store. Und ich habe heute mal beim Stream halt im Activity-Monitor geguckt und sieht auch aus wie 256 Kilobit. Das waren so 30 Kilobyte die Sekunde oder 32 Kilobyte die Sekunde. Das heißt, das müsste dann auch so hinkommen.
Die Wahrheit ist, Apple macht halt natürlich adaptive Streaming. Das heißt, je nachdem, wie deine Leitung ist.
Genau, das passt sich an.
Aber ich glaube, bei 256 ist dann auch Schluss.
Was hab ich denn gelesen?
Das kann ich dir nicht mehr genau sagen.
Also ich saß halt im Büro.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, das ist Apple Live-Streaming, HLS, da ist das einfach eingebaut. Also das...
Und ich habe im Office hier 10 Gigabit Faserleitung, da kann man schon mal dann...
Na, man kann ja im iPhone, im Developer-Modus kann man ja sagen, ich habe jetzt hier nur noch so und so viel Bandbreite und dann kann man das ja testen. Ja, glaub an der Qualität wird es da, das ist gar nicht kein Problem da.
Echt, hier sagt einer im Chat, Spotify gibt Vorbiss an. Naja, das wäre auch nicht...
Kann man auswählen bei denen, glaube ich.
Vorbiss. Also auf jeden Fall, sagen wir mal so, ich habe das jetzt mal, diese Tri-Version geklickt.
Auf dem iPhone? Die streamen Vorbiss aufs iPhone? Ja, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Da müssten sie ja diesen ganzen, kompletten Codec ins Software laufen lassen.
Wahrscheinlich streamen sie Vorbiss in den Firefox hinein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sowas, aber niemals aufs iPhone. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Auf jeden Fall interessiert mich dieses Beat, nicht dieses For You. Sah erst mal gar nicht schlecht aus, weil ich habe am Anfang, habe ich auf diese Kreise ein paar Mal geklickt und die werden ja auch größer. Du kannst ja so eine Gewichtung machen.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Tatsächlich waren die Playlisten, die sie dabei For You für mich kompiliert haben, erst mal gar nicht so doof.
Ja, die waren nicht verkehrt, aber doch auch relativ offensichtlich.
Aber ich habe das jetzt ehrlich gesagt wirklich geklickt, damit ich...
Was hast du eigentlich geklickt?
Also, hier diese...
Apple Music halt, die drei Monate erst mal. Du musst das ja anmelden.
Ja, aber ist das nicht nur für die USA?
Nee, das gibt es schon in der ganzen Welt.
Du gehst auf For You oder Für Dich und dann gibst du ja dieses Ding und wenn du da irgendwie auf die drei Monate kostenlos trialklickst, dann hast du das. Und wenn du aber in meine Musik klickst, dann machte das für dich weg. Das ist total bekloppt. Das kommt nicht wieder zurück.
Was auch nervt bei dem 8-4, wenn du den Log-Screen hast von deinem Telefon und du hörst aber zum Beispiel, also bei dem Beats Radio warst du, dann kam das Plattencover nicht. Wenn du erst gestoppt hast, dann kam es und wenn du wieder Play gemacht hast, ist es wieder verschwunden. Also es war genau dann da, wenn du es nicht gehört hast. Ich glaube, die müssen noch ein bisschen regeln und machen und tun.
Aber ich habe mir das vor allen Dingen wirklich zum Streamen hier auf allen Devices und ich werde das auch tatsächlich verschiedenen Familienmitgliedern einfach...
Du wirst die 15-Euro-Version klicken und...
Damit die auch einfach Ruhe haben. Ich mache das einfach mal klar und dann haben die auch einfach alle das und fertig.
Aber ist jetzt sozusagen, wenn ich jetzt diese 3 Monate Trial mache, habe ich dann auch automatische iTunes-Match sozusagen? Und was...
So lange wie es läuft.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, du hast nicht... Also dieses Match, das gibt es immer noch als extra Punkt. Das verhält sich schon ein bisschen anders. Weil, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist das bei dem iTunes-Match, da wäre es so, dass du siehst deine Library auf deinem iTunes mit allem, was du so hast aus verschiedenen Quellen. Und wenn du dieses iTunes-Match anhast, dann hast du genau deine Library auch auf dem Phone. Und das ist jetzt mit Apple Music nicht so. Sondern, was sie halt machen ist, zum Beispiel, wenn du Playlisten hast, dann werden die Playlisten da zwar schon bereitgestellt. Und dann ist es auch so, dass bestimmte Sachen, die sie nicht im Store haben und du siehst, die werden auf der Platte über iCloud gesynkt. Der Rest wird gestreamt. Aber im Wesentlichen siehst du deine Library eben nicht so wie auf dem Rechner. Sondern, wenn du jetzt einen Artist da hören willst auf deinem iPhone, dann musst du nach Let's Say Plan suchen und dann wird halt gestreamt. Und iTunes Match war, glaube ich, eher so wirklich so, du hast jetzt deine Libraries überall.
Und auch als lokale Kopie.
Aber angeblich hast du ja bei Apple Music wiederum auch, dass du sagen kannst, diese Files würde ich jetzt gerne mal auf dieses Device auch downloaden und so weiter. Und es ist tatsächlich in vielen Ländern verfügbar. Ich habe auf dieser apple.com/music, da ist irgendwo, in welchen Ländern das überall verfügbar ist. Und es ist wirklich viel. Also auch so kleine Nischenländer, ohne jetzt jemand auf den Schlips treten zu wollen. Aber diese Seite ist so furchtbar zu brausen, weil ich weiß immer nie, wo muss ich jetzt eigentlich hin, um diese Informationen zu bekommen. Also bei Membership war es, glaube ich, gerade, du kannst da oben auch auf Membership klicken und dann scrollt er an die richtige Stelle. Und dann gab es da, glaube ich, irgendwo eine FAQ noch dazu. Wo ist die FAQ? Und dann genau, hier steht, glaube ich, irgendwo, hier, in my country, complete list. Und jetzt siehst du hier, da wird es schon nach Afrika, Middle East und Indien schon mal aufgeschlitten.
Armenien, Oman, Kenia.
Also es ist quasi überall, wo der Store, glaube ich, auch verfügbar ist im Wesentlichen.
Das habe ich irgendwie komplett in den falschen Hals bekommen. Ich habe die ganze Zeit gedacht, die Nummer läuft nur in den USA.
Nee, es sind wohl diese Radiostationen. Also ich habe hier bei Radio, jetzt zumindest in der Firma, habe ich außer Beats One, diese ganzen anderen Sachen, die sie hier anbieten, habe ich alle nicht reingekriegt.
Obwohl du jetzt diesen Trial gestartet hast?
Ja, auch nach dem Trial, ja.
Aber dieses Apple Music, das gibt es, also dieses Streamen und iCloud Sync für die, falls sie sie nicht im Store haben, das gibt es schon. Und das Beste, was sie jetzt für mich noch tun könnten, wäre wirklich, wenn sie dieses Match da komplett mit integrieren und das als eigenes Produkt abschaffen, weil jetzt ist es in iTunes so, du kannst immer noch, da gibt es immer noch diesen Button hier, 24 Dollar im Jahr für iTunes Match, und dann denke ich mir so, Leute, also auch, dass sie launchen und dann haben sie keinen iTunes 2.
Was heißt denn das? Also wenn du jetzt das normale iTunes, das normale Apple Music, kostet 10er, also zahlst du 120 Euro im Jahr.
Ja, aber letztendlich...
Ja, aber wenn du es realistisch betrachtest, sind das 12 Albums, die du im Jahr kaufst. Na knapp, also sagen wir mal so.
Ich höre noch nicht mal 12 Albums, ja.
Für mich ist das wirklich schon ein bisschen... Also ich höre auf jeden Fall viel Musik und kaufe auch...
Auch viel Neues, weil du den ganzen Led Zeppelin hast du aber auch schon alles längst am Start.
Kannst dich legalisieren, Schockel.
Ja, jetzt muss ich da überhaupt gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenken. Also egal was.
Doch, wenn die damit eines Tages aufhören, dann ist alles wieder weg?
Ja, das was ja auch für mich noch das zusätzliche Feature wäre oder ist auch schon für Sachen, die sie nicht im Store haben, die kann ich dann halt auch einfach mal easy peasy über das Device oder über iCloud streamen und muss es nicht notwendigenweise auf dem Device haben. Das ist ja auch mal ein cooles Feature. Und wenn ich jetzt noch dieses Family-Dings dazu klicke und einfach meine gesamte Apple-isierte Familie da auch Teil daran haben kann, ohne dass sie weiter sich Stress machen oder irgendwie bei BitTorrent versuchen, irgendwelche Sachen rundes Land abgemahnt werden, super. Das erspart mir auch schon gleich wieder ganz viel.
Kommen denn diese Songs eigentlich immer gemixt? Also wenn so ein Song jetzt zu Ende ist und dann kommt der nächste, also spielen die wirklich so bis zur letzten Sekunde zu Ende?
In dem Apple Music auf jeden Fall. Bei iTunes gibt es ja dieses Crossfader-Setting.
Da kann man hier jetzt eine schöne Musik-Library zusammenbauen.
Und du kannst ja auch mit dieser Musik, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auch brennen. Du kannst jetzt nicht die Files kopieren, aber du kannst trotzdem damit schon ein bisschen mehr machen, als jetzt nur anhören sozusagen. Ich hab letztens auch einen Song mit Reaper von Spotify aufgenommen. Das ist so bescheuert. Ich hab ja hier mit Kassettendecks und so Mixed Tapes aufgenommen. Du kommst dir echt im 21. Jahrhundert so bescheuert vor, wenn du vor diesem Gerät sitzt und einfach die echte Spielzeit wartest, bis es verdammt nochmal überspielt oder aufgenommen ist. Und noch bescheuert ist es, wenn du es digital aufnimmst und daneben sitzt und denkst dir, boah, ist jetzt auch noch so ein 6-Minuten-Song, come on. Naja, aber ich glaube auch bei Apple Music, wie es bei Apple Maps war, wie es auch bei der Watch und wie es bei allem bei Apple ist, am Anfang rumpelt es noch so ein kleines bisschen und das schleift sich ein.
Manchmal rumpelt es auch nicht wie bei Ping und ist wieder weg.
Zum Beispiel bei Apple Maps, ich benutze jetzt wirklich fast null Google Maps, weil mittlerweile sind die Points of Interest und die Straßen und so bei Apple Maps einfach voll am Start.
Jetzt habe ich gleich von Ante angemacht.
Der Anzahl der Flughappen stimmt.
Ja doch, also in Berlin zum Beispiel ist echt, bin ich teilweise schon erstaunt. Schon gut. Nein, ich wollte nur sagen, dass bei allen Services oder Devices bei Apple das ja am Anfang so, wenn sie es einführen, da ist immer noch so ein bisschen Grain, was noch weggeschliffen werden will, ne? Und, also wie gesagt, was ich wirklich mega peinlich fand, dass sie launchen und dann gibt es das iTunes 12.2 noch nicht, ne? Und du musst nochmal...
Das muss irgendein Verleihstellungsfuck abgewesen sein, also...
Zeitzonen oder so.
Schaltsekunde, genau.
Sind wir schon durch?
Also durch bin ich auf jeden Fall schon, weil ich Anfang der Sendung gab. Ich auch.
Wir haben noch Kleinkram.
Wir haben noch Kleinkram?
Wer hat denn das mit dem Kleintand da reingeschrieben?
Das hab ich da reingeschrieben.
Mit dem was?
Roddy hat das reingeschrieben.
Ach, da unten sind wir.
Mit dem Kleintand. Ja, es gibt ein interessantes Feature in iOS 9, was ich noch nirgendwo gesehen hab, dass sie es besprochen haben.
Der Backbutton.
Der Backbutton, der lustigerweise...
Sagt, wohin er geht.
Nein, der hier oben in der Statusleiste ist. Unterhalb der eigentlichen Navigationsleiste von der eigentlichen App, sondern da oben, wo normalerweise irgendwie der Provider drin steht. Den fand ich irgendwie extrem witzig.
Das haben sie doch auf der Keynote auch vorgestellt. Das ist der Gang. Sie benutzen das an zwei Stellen vor allem erstmal. Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch weitere Stellen gibt. Bei der Suche. Also wenn du halt in Spotlight suchst und dann was findest, dann werden halt diese Suchergebnisse mit diesem Back to where I come from angezeigt. Und das zweite ist halt dieser neue Safari View Controller. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt einen Browser öffnest, weil da ein Link zu öffnen ist, der im Web angeschaut werden soll, du willst aber nicht aus deiner App verschwinden, dann musst du halt jetzt nicht mehr komplett den URL freien Lauf lassen und dann sind die Leute im Safari und kommen nicht wieder in deine App zurück. Stattdessen hast du halt diesen Safari View, der im Wesentlichen sich genauso bedient wie das normale Safari, nur dass du keine URLs eingeben kannst, sondern du kannst quasi nur ab da brausen, wo dieser Link her kam und alles, was danach antippbar ist, aber nichts anderes. Dafür musst du dann den Safari wechseln, aber du kannst dann auch immer wieder zurück in deine App und der Vorteil ist halt für die Apps, dass sie jetzt keine eigenen Web-Browser mehr programmieren müssen in diesen komischen Webviews und aus Passwort-Zugriff und Cookie und der ganzen...
Ich habe es noch an einer anderen Stelle gesehen, und zwar wenn du in Safari einen Link aufmachst, der wieder zurück in den App Store geht, dann wirst du ja von Safari wieder in den App Store umgeleitet. Und du kommst aber vom App Store auch mit dem Backlink wieder zurück nach Safari. Was ich auch ganz witzig fand.
Also sie machen das halt sehr, wie soll ich sagen, sehr zugeschnitten auf den jeweiligen Kontext. Aber Backbutton.
Of the feature of Android 1.0.
Ja, dieser Backbutton ist ja was anderes.
Konzeptionell ist schon ähnlich.
Noch einen kleinen Veranstaltungshinweis.
Ähnlich, aber nicht das gleiche. Ja, was ist?
Und zwar ist ja, was heute Mittwoch, ne? Morgen ist wieder der erste Donnerstag im Monat. Das heißt, na, ihr dürft raten.
Bagger fressen.
Genau, ist wieder in Room 77 in Kreuzberg in Berlin. Ist wieder Bitcoin-Meeting oder was auch immer. Die da so, da treffen sich alle Bitcoin-Interessierten. Also wer da mal vorbeischauen will oder vielleicht Bitcoins kaufen, verkaufen will oder was auch immer oder lecker nur Burger essen will und vielleicht auch sogar mit Bitcoin bezahlen will, der kann da mal hingehen, da ist morgen Bitcoin-Konzentration erhöht.
Dann gilt das ja nicht nur für morgen, sondern für jeden ersten Donnerstag im Monat.
Genau, aber jetzt gerade ist mir vorhin noch mal eingefallen, dass ja morgen mal so weit ist, weil meistens vergesse ich es selber immer. Ich merke es dann immer so abends, wenn es schon zu spät ist.
Tja, brauchst eine Uhr, die dich daran erinnert.
Ja, da muss man sich so einen Termin setzen, ne?
Ja, das könnte helfen.
Und ich habe ja da diese Bitcoin-Anzeige-Uhr gebastelt, die hängt da gerade nicht, weil die hatte gerade eine Macke. Aber eigentlich ist sie bei mir im Rucksack und ich müsste sie wieder hinfahren. Also wenn sie morgen nicht da hängt, dann habe ich es nicht geschafft. Wenn sie da ist und wieder geht, dann war ich vor euch da und habe sie da aufgedenkt. Mal schauen, ob ich das hinkriege.
Wie geht es da im Display im Restaurant?
Da war ich auch schon eine Weile länger nicht mehr, aber ich denke mal, dem geht es gut. Sonst da waren gestern ein paar Clubleute essen und dann hätten sie mir berichtet.
Ich hatte leider immer noch keine Gelegenheit, noch mal hinzugehen. überhaupt erstmal im Vollbetrieb zu beobachten. Das wäre in der Tat eine Option.
Die nehmen auch Bitcoins weiterhin, wisst ihr ja, und ich weiß nicht, ich könnte mir gut denken, das erste Bier ist noch nicht vergeben.
Fehlen den Bitcoins.
Wieder Richter. Ach echt? Hatte ich dir glaube ich auch schon das Erinnern? Ist das runtergefallen?
Ich war uns ja fast mal wieder die Wolle zu sinken.
Ich kann es ja ganz kurz erzählen, vielleicht haben wir auch Leute, die ein kleines Business betreiben. Und zwar gibt es halt den Anbieter, den wir genommen haben, da heißt es Bitpay. Man kann sich da über die Webseite anmelden, trägt da so ein paar Daten ein, also am Ende dann auch Steuernummer, Kontonummer und so weiter. Und das geht dann relativ schnell, wenn man alles richtig einträgt. Also wir hatten es innerhalb von 10 Minuten eingerichtet und irgendwie 2-3 Stunden später, weil wir wollten ein bisschen größere Summen einnehmen, weil ich glaube, das kleine ist nur so 100 Dollar am Tag oder so. Und das kann ja schon sein, wenn da mal 5 Leute sind, dass du dann über diesen Preis kommst. Da haben wir Tier 2 gewählt und da mussten erst, glaube ich, die Steuernummer gegenchecken oder weiß nicht, ob der da nochmal irgendwie einen Steuerbescheid hingefaxed hat, muss man ja heutzutage mal machen, damit sie wissen, alles klar, es stimmt einigermaßen. Und das ging innerhalb von 1-2 Stunden, haben die das bestätigt und dann konnten die da über so eine kleine Bitpay-App auf dem iOS, auf dem Tablet, was sie da benutzen, also iPad, konnte man damit Bitpay bezahlen und das ist so super easy. Man tippt die Summe ein, dann kommt der QR-Code, der Kunde bezahlt damit mit seiner App, wie auch immer er das macht. Die meisten Apps können ja QR-Codes und dann schon wieder eine Sekunde später wird aus dem roten Bildschirm ein grüner Bildschirm, was heißt, dass die Bezahlung angekommen ist und das war es dann schon. Also es ist so easy. Wahrscheinlich Leute, die Apple Pay benutzt haben, das ist genauso der Vorgang, du zahlst und das wird grün und fertig. Also einfacher geht es wirklich nicht. Und dieses Setup, das zu benutzen, ist auch total easy. Und der Stefan hat mir auch erzählt, dass einmal ein Kunde schon da war und auch mit Bitcoins bezahlt hat. Und das Geld war sogar am nächsten Tag, und ich glaube, Bitpay ist eine amerikanische Bude, das Geld war am nächsten Tag auf seinem Konto. Also wenn sich die Leute auch Sorgen machen, dass ihr dann monatelang oder sonst wie lange warten muss, bis dann das Bitcoin als Euro-Geld auf dem Konto erscheint. Nein, das geht sofort oder genauso schnell, wie bei, wenn Leute mit hier Mastercard und diesen ganzen Credit-Cards-Geschicht bezahlen, also man kriegt instantan sein Geld mehr oder weniger, also am nächsten Tag ist für Credit-Karten, glaube ich, genauso schnell wie die. Wenn nicht, sind die sogar langsamer, weiß ich nicht genau. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz einfacher Vorgang, wer irgendwie einen Laden hat, wo man was auch immer kaufen kann, wo die Kunden mit Bitcoins bezahlen könnten, der sollte das tun, weil es einfach cool. Ja, reicht ja auch. Also ich hätte gerne, dass ich irgendwo öfter was kaufen kann, wo man auch mit Bitcoins bezahlen kann. Ich würde das ja mega gut finden. Na, weil immer, wenn ich was kaufen will, dann besorge ich mir Bitcoins und dann gehe ich die ausgeben.
Du druckst ja dein Geld noch selbst.
Nee, nicht mehr.
Es sei denn, ihr wollt noch was über...
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob du... Ja, was ist das?
Na, es ist eine Anlage, wo man rumballern kann. Kannst ja Waffen mieten und Munition und für eine Stunde die Bahn, ist wie eine Kegelbahn, sieht das aus?
Nein, du warst nicht in den USA und hast irgendwo draufgehalten. Das verdirbt doch den Charakter.
Warte, warte, warst du nicht mit Pavel auch mal ballern?
Naja, aber das war ein deutscher, ordentlicher deutscher Schießstand.
Das war halt so ordentlicher.
Das war nicht so was, wo hier mit einer AK-47, bitte schön.
Genau.
Na, Roddy, weil ich das Schießgerät hatte.
Direkt neben dem Flughafen.
Da kommen die Leute auch mit ihren eigenen Gewehren, ne?
Na, Gewehre hatten sie jetzt nicht am Start, aber so Faustfeuerwaffen aller Art irgendwie. Naja, wir haben halt... Was hat sich denn dahingetrieben? Naja, ein Kollege war so der Meinung, er wollte eigentlich schon immer mal irgendwie ballern, so mit richtiger Wumme, mit richtiger Waffe. Und ein anderer Kollege war der Meinung, das ist doch mal eine prima Idee, lass uns das machen. Und dann hab ich halt auch mitgemacht. Und dann haben wir halt...
Mitläufer.
Genau, Mitläufer.
Kein Spielverderber sein.
Und dann haben wir da angerufen, ja, wie ist denn da? So Einführungskurs und so. Meinte, ja, prima. Und dann haben wir da den Einführungskurs gemacht. Und die hatten gleich das Gefühl, Leute, die erst mal nach dem Einführungskurs fragen, sind nicht ganz blöd. Und dann haben sie uns also vertraut und haben gesagt, ja, sagt einfach Bescheid, was ihr ausprobieren wollt.
Leute, die nach dem Einführungskurs fragen, sind sozusagen nicht so nachlässig, dass sie denken, sie können alles.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Ja, und dann haben wir da so insgesamt neun Faustfeuerwaffen, wie es so schön heißt. Neun? Neun verschiedene, ja. Was so? Na, so Revolver und was?
Ich kenne mich ja nicht aus. Eine schöne Magnum vielleicht.
Ja, so was in der Art.
Neun Millimeter bestimmt.
Ich habe, glaube ich, auf drei verschiedene Ballerinstrumente gebracht.
Und eine war relativ klein. Die haben wir da Noisy Cricket getauft. Und am krassesten war dieser 44 Smith & Wesson Revolver. Dieses Teil, das ist echt der Hammer. Du kannst es eigentlich nicht, auch mit zwei Händen, nicht halten. Also der Rückstoß, ich habe es auch jetzt nicht, man sollte da noch nicht verkrampfen, aber das Teil, das macht echt ordentlich Rückstoß. Und das Krasse am Revolver ist halt auch, der Blast geht halt hinten seitlich raus und du merkst richtig, wie es so warm wird.
Für kurz so. Aber wir waren ja hier mit Dennis und so, waren wir auch mal an so einem ordentlichen deutschen Schießstand, nicht? Und da war ja 9 Millimeter, ist ja das sowas, hier auch so Polizei und so, nymthne und dann, wenn du das mal abfeuerst, dann weißt du halt auch so die ganzen Filme oder Tate, wo die so rumspringen und so, noch so im Lauf, so hinterher schießen, das ist komplett unrealistisch, dass du da irgendwas triffst, was du treffen willst, weil das Ding halt auch schon so derbe einfach wegzieht.
9 mm ging da aber noch.
Das war auch schon mit beiden Händen. Also wenn du treffen wolltest, dann halt auch so stehen und so. Und wenn du dann irgendwo immer so in der See sehst, schmeißt man sich so hin und bang, bang, bang, das ist so glücklicher.
Das ist total absurd.
Wir durften auch mal eine 45er schießen. Also es ist ja 0,45 Inch, das sind ja 12 mm dann, oder knapp drüber, knapp drunter, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, und meine Fresse, da tut dir die Hand weh. Also nach jedem Schuss ist es erstmal, wie willst du deine Hand ausschütteln? Vielleicht kommt das mit ein bisschen Übung, weiß nicht, aber es hat schon Bums hinter.
Na klar, du hast ja die Muskeln nicht. Also wenn du jetzt wirklich regelmäßig schießt, dann trainierst du ja dann auch quasi Halterung.
Oder du hast halt eine Verkrampftraft. Also wenn man die relativ locker hält, naja, das Teil geht natürlich nach hinten, aber ich fand das jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Nee, das glaube ich auch nicht. Aber kommen lassen ist glaube ich nicht die richtige Idee.
Aber da irgendwie...
Da haust du dir das dann noch.
Aber ich fand 9 mm ziemlich okay.
Ja, es war okay, aber es hat halt trotzdem... Also man kann das schon mal machen, um sich mal einfach zu vergegenwärtigen. Was da für Kräfte... Jetzt quatscht du mir inzwischen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall ganz gut, um sich mal zu vergegenwärtigen, was da so für Kräfte im Spiel sind. Und mal vorher, wenn du das nur im Fernsehen siehst, dann sieht das halt aus wie Piff-Paff, Piff-Paff, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ich war auf jeden Fall sehr dankbar nach diesem Shooting-Range, wie man das wohl jetzt nennt, Besuch, dass es ziemlich verboten ist, dass Leute sowas einfach mal so im Schrank haben.
Das ist einfach kein Spaß. Genau, das hat uns auch der Typ da erzählt, wer überhaupt Waffen haben darf und was man machen muss, um überhaupt eine Waffe besitzen zu dürfen. Und er hat dann 15 Minuten dieses Waffengesetz da erzählt. Und dann dachte ich mir aber auch so, ja, okay, das klingt alles erstmal ganz beruhigend.
Aber er war schon auch ein Waffener und ist mit Waffe am Holztau rausgegangen zu seinem Auto. Also der trägt die dauerhaft, hat uns aber auch erklärt, das dürfen halt nicht viele. Das auch, wenn du ein Auto hast, dann musst du sie, also die darf auf jeden Fall nicht vorne sein, die muss im Kofferraum sein und von der Munition auch getrennt. Die darf nicht zusammen mit Munition irgendwie da liegen und zu Hause musst du sie wegschließen und so weiter.
Aber er meinte, also Förster, Polizisten, Militär natürlich sowieso und Leute, die halt sozusagen so Waffen transportieren, die müssen auch eine Waffe tragen, also auch das Sicherheitsdienst für Banken, Geldtransporter, ne? Und weil, wenn halt irgendwelche üblen Gestalten halt so ihnen jetzt überfallen würden und die ganze Kiste ausräumen, dann muss er halt irgendwie schon ein bisschen gegen...
Aber zu welcher der Kategorien gehörte er denn?
Nee, er war sozusagen... Also Sportschützen sind halt so Leute, die halt Waffen transportieren, weil er lässt die ja nicht in den Schießstand, er nimmt die sozusagen wieder mit.
Achso, nicht Transporteur, sondern jeder, der sie transportiert.
Ja, der halt die Lizenz zum Transportieren hat, wahrscheinlich ja.
Ja, okay, aber jetzt ein normaler Schütze hat die ja so in dem Sinne...
Ja, nee, es geht schon explizit um, du hast ein Auto, wo kistenweise Munition oder was auch immer drin sind und du bist da eben entsprechend ein attraktives Ziel für die Gesichtslosen.
Die haben die Kisten ja zu diesem Shooting Range da mitgebracht, also weil der Shooting Range, der macht nichts weiter, wie die Kegelbahnen, die Bahnen vermieten, aber die haben gar keine Waffen da und nichts, sondern du zahlst da für die Stunde und dann darfst du da auf irgendwie Scheiben schießen und wieder rum, aber die haben keine Waffen da.
Auf der Kegelbahn kriegst du aber die Kugel in der Regel dazu.
Da schon, im Shooting Range nicht, sondern der Typ hat halt, wir waren in zwei Teams, ich glaube, wir haben drei Waffen pro Team, also wir haben sechs Waffen da irgendwie mitgebracht und dann hat er uns halt da erzählt und gemacht.
Na ja, in Amiland war das halt so, dass du durftest keine eigene Munition mitbringen, das war die Regel dort. Du musstest dort die Munition kaufen, aber die hatten halt relativ viele unterschiedliche Sachen da und man hat halt nichts dafür bezahlt, dass man erstens dort war und zweitens mal halt die Waffen benutzt hat. Also Munition hat gekostet und diese Zielscheiben.
Der Stalker-Patronen-Mobil.
Also sie haben sozusagen nur an die Patronen verdient.
An den Patronen und an diesen Zielblättern da. Waren da Personen drauf? Ja, sehr stilisiert.
Das ist in Deutschland verboten übrigens. Du darfst nicht mal auf Blätter mit Personen draufschießen. Also bei der Polizei machen, das ist vielleicht keine Ahnung, aber normalen Shooting-Range bis dann dürfen da nur Kreise sein.
Ja, bei der Polizei machen sie das unter Garantie.
Naja, da war halt so ein stilisierter Oberkörper, aber auch so mit eingezeichneten Zonen und so. Und da meinte, wir sollen nicht auf den Kopf schießen, weil dann würden wir die Decke treffen. Und Decke treffen kostet extra.
Es war kein offener Shooting-Range, sondern auch in einem Gebäude. Ja, dann ist doch mit dem Flughafen gar nicht so schlimm.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber wir haben uns trotzdem gewundert, dass es irgendwie wegnehmen wird.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite sitzen da vielleicht zwei, drei Leute nebeneinander in so einer Shooting-Range und haben da beide so eine fette Wumme in der Hand. Und wenn die sich jetzt entscheiden, mal kurz rauszurennen, dann haben sie ja auch eventuell schlagende Urgabe.
Wenn eh alle mit Knarren rumrennen in Amiland, ist das auch alles ihr Wurscht.
Das Einzige, was ich merkwürdig fand, war, dass es halt wie Silvesterfeuerwerk war. Das war so das, was ich irgendwie nicht erwartet hatte.
Nur fast ein bisschen lauter, ne?
Schwarz-Bröber halt.
Fast ein bisschen lauter ist gut. Wir hatten Ohrstöpsel und Gehörschützer oben drüber.
Und eine Brille.
Ja, keine extra Brille.
Aber ja, genauso. Ohrstöpsel und das Ding, es war trotzdem noch laut.
Ja, aber nicht unangenehm.
Mit sechs Millimeter haben wir auch geschossen. Das war eher so witzig.
Hat man es mal gemacht. Ich brauch das nicht nochmal.
Genau, das war auch meine Erkenntnis. Einmal reicht.
Ja, das ging mir auch so. Mehr nicht.
Ich muss mal hier für kleine Podcaster machen wir jetzt Schluss oder?
Ja, wir machen jetzt Schluss. Das ist eine gute Idee. Die Liste ist abgearbeitet.
Wir auch.
Wir sind auch abgearbeitet. Und wir sehen uns ja ohnehin. In zwei Wochen schon wieder, weil mein Reiseplan, mein schnifflig ausgearbeiteter Reiseplan, das ermöglicht. Vokel, sag doch einfach schon Tschüss.
Genau. Ich bin nicht da. Nächstes Mal, da bin ich schon an Bord von der SV Matenka.
Du kannst ja live berichten.
Ja, ich schenke euch was.
Habt ihr da Internet auf dem Wasser?
Gelegentlich, ja.
Dann können wir ja mal gucken, wo ihr seid. Gibt es einen Live, wo man ist?
Ja, ich kann das gucken.
Du kannst ja mal Franz Freischein machen. Ja, hab ich.
Wir sind ja dicke Kumpels und da geht das.
Ja, verstehe.
Jetzt, mach mal. Also, wieder schauen.
Tschüss. Bis bald. Oder wie das immer so schön heißt. Tschüss, bis nächste Sendung. Und da ist dann Clemens wieder da. Genau. Nee, da weiß ich gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich glaube, Clemens ist tatsächlich längere Zeit nicht dabei.
Ich glaube, er meinte zwei nicht, der ist zum Camp wieder da.
Genau, aber zum Camp wird ja sowieso alles gut.
Das heißt, nächste Folge sind wir zu dritt oder hast du einen Gast?
Mal gucken. Das werden wir dann sehen. Und bis dahin lassen wir alles offen. Viel Spaß beim Ausprobieren von all dem, worüber wir gerade geredet haben.
Genau, kompiliert schön. Tschüss.